Firing.
The kid said,
sans kid friendly shops here.
It's the kiss as a kid,
we know.
We don't know.
We're not mad at Brian Cowen.
We Love Brian.
Count.
Brian counts just in New York working.
Uh,
so save at Twitter trolls.
Save it.
Settle down.
Something must have at uh,
Eddie Bravo hedge surprise here.
No Eddie Bravo and Brendan shop
or not upset at each other.
Stop it.
Stop at Twitter.
Tolls.
Twitter trolls are fucking crazy.
Try so hard at each other.
Look at the way they look at each other.
I saw the way he looked
at him when he said that.
Like,
how's your son?
Shout out the love of our lives.
Real off camera.
I hate each other.
Shout out to the Colorado
Springs Fire Department.
Donald Cowboy Cerrone,
his dad gave me this shirt.
Sick cowboy.
His Dad works for the Colorado
Springs Fire Department,
Colorado to the show.
I think it feels like you're
trying to take Joe away road.
I mean,
it feels,
it feels like that to me.
I don't want to talk about it.
And they're like high school where
your new friend get the friend.
Yeah.
He's tried to take it in front of him.
That becomes a real issue with
people for grown men sometimes,
bro.
I mean,
you're hanging around
with him all the time.
I mean,
I just wonder,
I wonder Bro,
what the fuck is going on?
I mean,
we're just,
what's happening with our friendship,
man.
I've had this conversation
recently with a older friend.
Oh no need.
Oh,
it's also when dudes get older and shit,
shit gets stale in their life.
You know,
people start getting real desperate.
They get real weird.
If you,
if you know a dude who has a
job but he doesn't enjoy it.
He's been doing it for a long time and
he's in a relationship is not real whole
lot of fun and you know,
you stop hanging around
with them a little bit.
It's like,
oh my God,
everything's going dark.
Yeah man,
Where's the fun?
Where's the fucking fun?
Where's the blood?
There's no fun.
Can't hang out.
It seems like nowadays with Instagram,
the way it's set up in Facebook,
you can't fucking talk as much shit
as you could like eight years ago.
On the Internet when it was like,
it was like,
it was cool to have like
some stupid screen name,
like you know,
red dog two 83 or something like
that and you're just anonymous.
There's still some of that
like on the underground,
you know,
a lot of anonymous dudes,
they're there like secret.
You see there's sort of anonymous,
but the problem is their Ip
addresses are known like you.
Not really that it's your only anonymous.
If someone doesn't look,
no one's anonymous anymore.
If you're posting things,
hey,
you might think you are,
but even if you're going
behind a couple of proxies,
it's just,
it's not hard to find you.
It's a weird world.
There was a guy that was a troll on
Reddit's a famous story because he was a
like a real nasty guy.
Apparently they found out where he worked.
These people went after him.
They found out where he worked,
they found out who the guy
is and they got him fired,
fired from his job because his,
his fun shit.
What he would to do is he,
you know,
I mean if you looked at
it from a psychologic as a
psychological point of view,
you would say,
oh,
this guy's like all bent up and like
held back at work and he has some anger
issues and he gets online and
through this anonymous account,
he does a lot of mean shit and it
goes after people in the morgue.
Yeah.
He,
I think he,
I don't remember the rest
story that shoot up the place.
Yeah.
I mean who knows what level of,
so I mean it might not,
that might not be the choice.
It might be just he's an asshole.
But my point is they found this guy,
they found this guy and they got
him fired and that's going to,
that's just like what they can do today.
Did you see that'd be able to do what
happened with a nine year old from getting
bullied at school and on
the line committed suicide.
Nine kids fucking Nice.
That is so crazy.
Was smart enough at nine to how
to figure out how to hang it.
So you don't want to see,
I should go after those people
instead of fucking terrorists.
That's true.
They are terrorist.
I mean the hormone after some people they,
they went after that one kid.
There was a kid who was a roommate in
college with a kid who is gay and he knew
his friend was gay.
So he set up a camera and filmed
his friend having sex with a guy.
And I don't know if he blackmailed him
or said something and the guy wound up
killing himself.
So now he's on trial for,
I think,
I don't know what they're saying.
Manslaughter may be or new shit.
Some something,
something awful.
There was a similar case
where this girl was,
uh,
that she knew her friend
was like manic depressive,
bipolar and she,
and he would reach out to for
like help and she was like,
you just need to kill yourself,
kill yourself.
And then they have all this,
the texting history and then she
would send them links on how to do it.
And then he finally did it.
And he texted goes,
I think it would do it tomorrow night.
She goes,
you're so full of shit.
You're not going to do it.
Let me know if you do.
And they end up doing it.
So now she's being charged
with it and she's really young.
And here's the problem with that.
When you're real young,
first of all,
they say your brain isn't
even really fully formed.
It doesn't even like your,
your thoughts don't come and like the
most logical manner until you're like deep
into your twenties I think they say your,
your frontal cortex is,
I probably shouldn't be talking
at all about like science,
but I think what the term was about,
it was about decision making
and impulsive decision making,
particularly in young
men experiencing texts.
Testosterone for the first time.
Thinking about this,
think about you're young,
right?
You're experiencing testosterone
when you're 1314 years old.
So you've got 13 years of confusing life.
All of a sudden you got raging boner.
So I'm just get sign.
And you're so baffled because
you're so horny all the time.
And,
and,
and sex is everything.
It's [inaudible] TV show,
TV shows and selling cars and it's
all over the fucking little boards.
I used to jack up the covers a city,
those fucking girls in
the volleyball games.
Right.
And we were talking about that.
We're talking about the other day,
like how can they,
they're wearing thongs,
but the point is when you're young,
you do shit.
He might not even understand the
consequences of what you're doing.
Like the idea that this girl knew that
this guy was going to kill himself and
that being mean,
it was anything other than for her.
Just a fun game of being mean.
Magnitude of it.
I don't know if you can
really say that they know.
I mean,
it's awful that it got done
and I'm not exonerating her,
but I don't know if you could
really treat that person.
Should adults and then add in head trauma
if they played football or did martial
arts.
So yeah.
Oh yeah.
Try playing football since you were six.
Does that you?
Yes sir.
Dude,
keep it together very well.
You'd be surprised.
When I leave the students
I get online and you see the new CTE study
that they just released as an article
that was out today where they were
saying that it is not the amount of
concussions,
it's the amount of time
you've been in the head.
So it's subconcussive trauma,
like just jabs to the face that
don't even knock you out way,
way over long periods
of time can be worse.
You know,
here's like I was watching Hbo
boxing the other night and a when uh,
Gennady Golovkin fought
a Kell Brook Brook,
amazing,
amazing fight for as long as it lasted.
I understand why Brooks
corner threw in the towel.
I was bummed out that they did,
but he was going to get marked.
Hundred percent was getting
Mercked they were smart.
They were smart.
But I was upset because I was like,
God damn,
this is a good fight.
Me Too.
I Kid Kell Brook is very good.
Anyway,
point being Bernard Hopkins is doing
the commentary and I'm listening to him
doing a commentary and I'm like,
when you see a guy who's that great of a
boxer like Bernard Hopkins and has been
involved in boxing like pretty much
his whole life and he's almost,
he might be 50 now.
He's right around right before he is 50
and the last time he fought he fought
Kovalev and got boxed up.
You know,
it was a tough fight to watch cause
you're watching really an older Bernard
Hopkins getting hit hard by a murderer.
I mean Kovalev is so
good too in the world.
Yeah.
But I was listening to him commentary.
When you listen to a guy
like that commentate,
he like,
well he talks pretty good now,
but what's it going to
be like in 10 years?
You know like when you,
when you hear a guy
that talks really well,
like deep in his fifties and
sixties like George Foreman,
like how did he pull that off?
Some guys keep it together though,
don't they?
Like Roy Nelson should be drooling out
of his mouth and shitting his pants.
Just
did a maximal Blanco on maximum Blanco.
Now young have got gay teen,
no son [inaudible] he switched it up.
He has the dark cells.
It's over.
He's out,
he's out,
he's out.
He's out son.
Oh my God.
Type move.
Heather referee not knowing he
was out right there on the edge.
Kid.
Sounds like Tony Ferguson.
Right?
Herb.
That's her best of the world.
You know what man,
we is even an opportunity,
you know,
be and the angle sometimes her,
her,
I usually give the benefit of the doubt
cause he's one of the best and it's not,
I think he is wrong with
going out to him and John Out.
I agree with the tap.
It's you're right.
Well it's a fight.
You're right.
I agree too because going
out doesn't hurt anybody.
It looks like it hurts you.
It doesn't do anything bad.
Even if you do lose some brain cells,
what are we doing?
And we're trying to brain cells here.
It'd be nice.
I mean I don't,
that's not what this is about.
It's about the guys who are
sacrificing their brains for us.
What's,
what's going on.
I like to think.
I think herb dean and
John McCarthy are equal.
I think they're equal at the very top,
I think to the best and that.
What cars do you mean?
Numero uno?
Numero Uno.
As far as dealing with them personally,
when they come in the back and just
the way I felt if John McCarthy was in,
was working my fight.
I felt so much better.
This is a beautiful dark man.
He didn't quite get the guillotine so it
just perfectly because as maximum rolls
out of the guillotine rolls right
into the dark and transition.
It was beautiful.
I Bet Chaz is hit that
transition a hundred times.
He just tell right away you can sell
that this was his shit and his arms are
long and it was in deep
and he ain't going nowhere.
He's fresh.
It's over and by the look at
the guy's face to defending,
right.
He should have went.
I mean he,
he should have grabbed the inside of his
thigh immediately when when he put that
on.
I would like to hear what him and herb
were just saying to each other term was
asking him a question
about how he set that up.
See,
Herb's are legit martial artists,
you know,
educated,
but he loves it.
Like when he's asking there,
he wants to know,
look at this dude.
They both start off cause
that's what Maxima always does.
He got a tight perfect look how
he set it up for doom though.
Don't get it twisted.
Damn.
That was beautiful.
Yeah.
Professional,
right.
They're looking at
building chill,
chill and just showed up with an
80 pound watch on how dare you.
How dare your ball so hard.
How Terry Ball.
So dairy ball so hard.
Look at gold on gold.
That's a couple of Goldie's over.
I was a girl.
I would be attracted to you
just because of that watch.
It's fancy.
Yeah.
I would say something about him.
He's all tattooed up.
You look scruffy and dangerous.
He's got scar tissue.
Sky's the deal.
Closer.
They look at the watch and go Bam.
That's it.
That's what you're saying.
I got a lot of cash patch.
He's still balling in that crazy corvette.
No,
not,
not anymore.
When you driving now?
Oh,
just a range rover.
Just safe and comfortable
motor sports though.
It should be something else coming soon.
What corvette was it?
A Z zero six counterparts.
Never mad at Czi convert to dope.
Dope car man.
Yeah,
the,
you know what man?
It's,
it's interesting to see how far they've
taken performance cars and how far they
have left to go cause
there's nowhere left to go.
Like those was insane Teslas.
Then when you put them on ludicrous
mode and they're zero to 60 in like less
than three seconds.
I don't fuck like the electric
does nothing for the very fast.
My Dick Goes,
Huh?
Nah,
but you bring up fucking nasty ass split
windows sting ray or something like
that.
Yes sir.
Yeah,
but what about the environment?
I'm sure we'll figure it
out at least of our worries.
I just can't believe they
haven't figured it out yet.
I just feel like there's gotta be a way,
like I read something about China.
I might,
I don't know even know
if it was a real article,
but they had developed a thing that was
like a large and it was an air filter.
It would,
it actually would pull the pollution
out of the city air and they build
something,
a guy,
giant powered filter.
It's all sides of the building.
100%.
Makes Sense.
It seems like you could
completely clean the air,
but then the real trick would be
to get it to run on pollution.
If you add a filter that actually use
the carbons in the air as it's fuel and
then sucked all that shitty air
in and pumped out clean air.
There are some smart ass people
can for sure work on that.
Yeah,
there's not enough money in
it after the scuffle problem.
The car companies like it floats
up after the last podcast we did.
I remember we were leaving
the conversation we had,
we got into solar panels.
Yeah,
and like I'm,
I don't,
I'm confused as to how they work.
You are super confused.
Are there,
are there guys out there that have solar
panels and they're just completely cut
off the grid and they're just using
all their energy is from them.
Solar panel hundred percent seems like
every time you hear about the solar
panels,
the way it works is you sent
the energy back to the city.
No,
no,
no.
Discounted rent.
Here's the deal.
First of all,
if you see someone who was like,
I have a friend was a
house that's in Colorado,
that's completely off the grid,
never been on the grid.
It's all solar panels,
solar panels,
beautiful and solar panels and they have
a propane backup in case something goes
wrong with the solar system or it goes
down that cause it gets so fucking cold,
it gets so cold.
Motherfucker [inaudible]
solar system shuts down.
Excuse me.
Solar power system.
Yeah,
that's
dead on the report.
The fucking earth boiler.
Mars is headed
one light.
So yeah.
What they try to do,
and this is what happens
most of the time in la,
like if you see someone set
up a solar power system,
it's tricky because it's
not really independent.
You get your power from the sun,
but it pumps right back into the grid.
Your Po connected to the grid.
So that's what I'm talking about.
You don't have to be,
it's just cheaper.
Exactly.
Pushing,
not pushing that they're going,
hey,
it's,
it's like why does the city need,
oh we need some space
and we need your roof.
You know,
just get,
why are they to,
you keep saying you keep saying
this and you're wrong about that.
You keep,
you keep using that analogy.
Listen,
they're not,
they don't need the power from
these people that have solar power.
Now what it is,
what they're doing is they don't want
to disconnect from the grid because they
don't want to lose money.
First of all,
it's really hard.
It's really hard to get off that grid.
It's really hard to
just get on electricity.
Callins been trying for
how many months now?
He's
been doing it for like four months.
Going back and forth.
So what they do,
one foot in,
one foot out,
you gotta be all in.
Well doesn't have a
contractor who's doing it.
[inaudible] you never know.
You never know.
He's your friend.
You would know.
I mean,
I know he's my friend too,
my friend first
though.
Right?
You're basically saying
I was being sarcastic.
What you're saying is you,
you're thinking that somehow
or the grid needs the power.
That's definitely not what it is.
More expensive.
It's more generative when
you just get solar power.
Okay.
You don't need this.
Just Massive Bank of batteries.
You don't need a lot of equipment.
There's a lot of shit when
you go completely off the
grid so that when you cut
your power off,
you're not connected to anything.
If you cut your solar off,
you're still connected to the regular
power grid and you still get regular power
if you're solar goes down.
It's one of the advantages that people
like about staying connected to the grid.
You say [inaudible] to the other part is
you definitely save money and get 100%
you get a taxi,
but you also can,
if you don't,
if you make more power than you use,
it actually goes back into the
grid and you can get money from it.
Boom.
That's what it is,
but it's not like they need it.
It's sort of an incentive.
It's an incentive in a way to
stay connected to the grid,
which I think for them is like a survival
technique because if everybody in
California,
you've got solar and if solar keeps
getting better the way everything gets
better,
you're going to have a soul that's as
big as this fucking table and it's going
to be able to power j Lo's house.
That'd be so expensive.
It has comments and that's why
people bring better and better.
It's just really expensive now,
but it's battery technology
needs to improve.
There's a lot of issues.
Elan Musk is on the ball with that shit.
He's created these batteries
that sit on your wall.
It's hanging on the wall and there's much
smaller profile than the standard shit
that most people have in their houses.
So what does it do?
Well,
it's just,
they're just large batteries that store
the electricity from the solar power
system.
You can use them.
Yeah.
And you just need,
yeah,
you need whore.
Yeah.
The Bat.
It has to be collected.
It's like you,
have you ever seen those solar things
that you can use to charge your phone?
They're pretty dope.
It's like a,
like a laptop.
Like you open it up and you lay it,
you can just let it sit on a rock and
it'll soak up enough energy from the sun
to power your phone.
At the end of the day.
If my friend who backpack heights,
my friend Adam,
he's actually in Montana right now,
he uses that to send these updates
from the top of the fucking mountain.
That's what he's using for his power.
He's got this solar thing
and he'd just unfold.
Makes sense if you do all that shit.
But if you live in La,
don't bring that shit out.
Well just charge it in your car.
But if you have a card that's yeah,
that's probably good.
Yeah,
but if you're an Uber all the
time or something like that,
what if you're responsible and
can look at that book and thing?
Just charge your cell phone.
Ah,
let me just get up it.
Fucking backpack full of solar panels.
But no,
it folds up.
See,
it folds up in three panels.
Collapse together.
So it's like a laptop,
iPad.
So it's not that much
bigger than you fucking,
I'd a solar panel on the back.
Your goddamn damn phone.
Just like God ain't going like that.
That's under Lou Fisker,
Flipkart this,
check this out.
Fisker.
They've got a new one.
You know,
they blew up and they kind of went
out of business or wanted one.
They only think it went well.
These,
these apparently won't blow up.
What happened was if you
don't know the story,
there was a hurricane came,
all the ones around the dock in North
Carolina exploded when the water hit them.
I was about to get one too for steel.
So now they have one that has a roof.
Check it out.
Eddie,
look behind you.
That's a Fisker thing.
Sick.
So the roof on these
things is solar powered.
The roof can actually power the car,
allegedly.
That's crazy.
Well,
in somewhere like la totally makes sense,
right?
He just as we have so much sun,
Phoenix,
shit,
Seattle and Seattle,
you're going to,
you'll starve to death
and parts of the country.
You would think that,
I mean you could use it.
There's enough heat to
power everything that car.
See,
what does it say?
It says,
does it say it will hold the whole car
guarantees about a mile and a half a
propulsion per day.
So we're roof feeds the main battery
and generates about a mile and a half of
propulsion per day.
That ain't shit.
Yeah.
That's a waste of my fucking time.
What does that mean
today?
Okay.
Oh,
this is that.
Park your car at the airport for a week
and get home on the power of his son and
the son.
Maybe if you live seven miles away,
but God damn,
you're pushing it and god,
I mean that's just pushing us.
Yeah.
What did you hit traffic and you
see that meter going down your turn,
your radio off.
You want that gas can right there.
I had like gas to the old school I the
electricity is a is a fascinating future
for sure,
but Maine early adopters that you,
you're right now you're not really
early adopter like a mid time adopter,
but it's a pain in the ass.
When I rented one,
they don't last that long.
Like I,
I went to the Improv and back home and
it was more than a half of a battery.
They're just not fun either.
Like I enjoy driving,
I love driving.
Let me sit in traffic.
I don't,
but I love driving WCH I'm like that in,
in,
in the Tesla.
It's just,
it's not fun for me.
But you had that Prius.
Could it not be fun and I fucking would
kick it every time I got to get into it.
I sold that thing so fast.
All right.
When the lease was up so they get the
shit out of my face and he did it.
I drove a Tesla ones.
It can't stand the hell
tried driving a real sports.
Oh yeah.
I don't know.
Jump in that.
You're like that.
I think they're pretty bad ass.
I see Eddie's point.
Cool.
Finally an electric car.
That looks cool cause like
pimps fucking drive though.
The fiscal.
The Fisker.
Fisker looks like a Maserati or a Tesla.
Cool.
Finally they look better than a Prius.
Yeah,
definitely.
They've definitely look cool.
Like Brian's that white one.
That looks pretty
serious of bummed me out.
Yeah Chris.
So fuck your day up.
It's transportation though.
I mean that's what it is.
It's not,
there's a difference between a vehicle
and like a that corvette that you
were driving at zero six convertible.
That thing is just a rollercoaster ride.
It's stressful to drive it to like,
is this kind of stressful
to drive it too much power,
too much power.
Like the Ferrari.
I like the friary better but they're
about the same like speed wise.
I mean they're about as fast.
You can't tell really if I raced one
or the other it'd be just as fast.
But like the Ferrari,
the passengers terrified.
You feel like you're in total
control and the corvette,
you're both fucking tear.
You just,
you have no control and
like the ass and just go.
It's six 50 horsepower and six
50 torque and it's fucking crazy.
Many dodge vipers when they first
came out was the first car really?
That was on mass production.
I was a 500 horsepower,
500 pounds of Torque and guides.
It was just like crazy eyes off Mr deeds,
they're like,
these things are fast and just
to run into walls and shit.
They have a new bunch stick to do.
Have you seen that new viper that they
have built just for the race track but
you could drive it around the street.
It's insane.
It is like the closest thing
you can get to a dick on wheels.
I was like a giant space ship date.
Oh they bring it up right now.
We all get a car guy every hole.
Pull the,
pull that thing up.
Look at this thing down.
The fucking thing is so God
damn fast to 12 Donnie fast.
What years?
That one Jamie?
2017 it's a scary ass car too.
I want that 1993 old school,
that 40 g's viper.
They keep taking these things to race
tracks and breaking the track record over
and over and over again.
It's just a monstrous car,
but ridiculous to dry UCR.
Is that right?
Yeah,
but if she drew this,
the SRT ACR,
I think there's 12 or what?
I don't know what it is.
I think it's the other ones.
12 getting away from B12 12 feet.
10 look at the Viper.
Afford Christ.
What's for like baby has a
Ford gt best depth thing.
It's an amazing,
the Shelby Cobra about
you see the new one?
They've got a new one coming out.
No,
I just remember the pro,
like the old one.
The Gt just looked like a door.
It was just ugly door was goofy.
I had one of those,
I believe.
I dig them.
What's the,
the Nissan Gtr,
they have one of the
fastest cars ever accurate.
Doesn't really have,
they have an NSX.
It's coming accurate.
Then sex is,
they'd make a new one,
but it's not like the old one.
The old one was like a stick shift.
Light car,
aluminum.
The new one is four
wheel drive turbo audit.
It's automatic.
The Nissan GTR though,
at my age,
especially your guys' age,
you'd feel like a dick
driving cause it's like
the first time you ever gotten
high it was too much supra ish.
A little bit like if
you were in high school,
he'd be killing it.
Killing it.
Killed the GTR.
Yeah.
Like sage Northcutt pulls up to the club.
That's his fucking car.
That's what he's got.
Yeah.
He has a gts.
Perfect sense.
It's perfect.
Perfect for him.
That is has,
I can't think of a handsome
fellow with a slick rod.
It's like,
right.
Those are fun cars though,
man.
Who gives a fuck what anybody else thinks.
When you show a hundred
horsepower or something,
hey listen man,
you think people don't think you're
a Douche bag when you pull up in that
continental gt,
easy Bentley Super Sport.
It's only 200 of them.
Big Difference.
It's a bad for what I thought when
I pulled up and parked outside,
I was like,
oh,
this fucking Douche bag.
That's a dope car.
That's it.
That's a GTR and that car is silly,
fast,
stupid fast,
and they handle like a dream man.
I rented one of those.
You could rent them from Hertz.
Hertz rent summit in Austin.
I rented one for a few
days and drove it around.
So amazing.
Great car.
Just not for you.
You rented the Hellcat too?
Yeah,
we're in negative fucking awesome.
Yeah.
So ridiculous.
You laughing when you drive in it.
Yeah.
It's got 660 something fucking
orders it 700 750 it's just crazy.
What do you go from there though?
It's crazy.
Where does dodge go from there?
Who knows?
Well that's what we're saying.
You know about like the,
you know,
the evolution of this stuff.
It's,
it's,
they're trying to have unlimited
growth in performance cars.
It's going to get to
some weird place where,
I mean it is already,
if you can go and buy one of those z I
o six is you could be an 18 year old kid
and go out and buy a corvette.
Z O six and for,
for what that is it and don't get,
I realize that expense for
what that car's performance is,
it's cheap.
Oh Gosh,
that's terrible.
Well,
sort of affordable housing
dog car cars though.
It seems like every year
the zero to 60 gets a B.
Yeah.
What point does it stop?
Exactly?
That's what we're saying.
Well the electric ones are beaten,
beaten,
all the,
everything that ludicrous shit.
They're getting nuts.
Yeah,
they're pretty close.
I think that the older model was
the insane button and [inaudible]
yeah.
Meatballs or whatever.
There's going to be like,
no Chris.
It's a weird car,
man.
It's a weird car.
You know?
It's ridiculously fast.
But yeah,
going to get to get it down
to probably like one second.
I wonder if the government's
going to like step in.
I mean they keep you
from doing certain shit.
How come they don't keep you
from driving motorcycles?
I was thinking that while I was watching
this guy zip past me on the highway
today is
with a girl on,
it's insane.
I was like,
ah,
please don't fall.
And just watching them
go and please don't fall.
Just,
just,
I don't want to see you guys
turn it to me on the road.
Like so insane dude on uh,
unfollow on Thursday I was in the
Beverly Hills like kills here.
I'm coming down and I'm at the light.
I had a long damn like God damn,
that's a long day.
Like feeling sorry for
myself for whatever reason.
And this fucking car is making a lefthand
turn and these young kids are paying
attention.
They're like talking and looking back.
Probably going 60.
I'm like go,
this ain't good.
Good.
The front,
the bolt,
the cars is basically ripped off engine.
I mean,
just a complete shit show.
The kids that hit the car get out.
They're fine.
Like some foreign kids,
girls pretty hot anyways.
They get out.
The car that they hit was like a Cadillac
cts or whatever it brand new with the
temp tags.
An older lady gets out,
I'm watching like,
what the fuck is this?
So lady gets out and she's crying.
She goes to the side,
they got hit,
her husband's there and
they can't get them out.
I was like an unconscious Cancun.
Not so much shit.
I better do something.
So I pull off the side,
I run over there,
finally getting him out and I
look at him in his fucking grill.
He must have hit the front and his,
his teeth,
his lip,
it just blood everywhere,
man.
Gangster.
He's like,
did you see what fucking happened?
Juicy.
I didn't want to be a witness.
There's a million other people.
And like,
I sure didn't man.
Good luck.
And I called nine one one.
You didn't want to be a witness.
You know how they got,
well,
I helped them and there's enough
people around where they can,
there's literally 50 other witnesses.
I don't know if you
should have admitted that.
Uh,
believe me,
they had it.
They had it.
I have to get going,
get home to my son now.
No,
they got it for sure that there was
literally 50 people around saw the same
shit.
They don't need fricking
my play by play on it.
That makes sense.
It sounds a little better.
They don't.
They're fine.
There's cops everywhere.
CSI was on that shit.
So who's fault was it?
Was it the kid's fault?
The kids?
Yes.
Yeah.
Hundred percent yeah man.
It is amazing when you think that someone
should can give you a car when you're
17 years old,
when you're,
I remember being,
well,
I got a bunch of car accidents
when I was having too bad,
but I was so stupid.
I was so dumb.
I was so dumb and completely reckless.
And the idea that someone just gave me
a 2000 pound plus thing with an engine
and not smash ball.
He's barely know how to fucking pay
attention to the breaks and the oil.
And you're barely,
and you're,
you're a part of this now at cell phones
into the mixed kids are addicted to
cell phones and do a triangle
Twitter and all that shit.
Just got to shift a little to the right,
my friend.
Good Stat to scoop that hip out.
Readjust.
Hmm.
Nope.
Oh,
good stacking hay.
Do you Eddie,
do you still do the TP?
Is that still a legit damn,
remember the teepee?
Yes.
It's still totally legit.
It is right.
I just don't,
haven't gone to it.
And you gotta be kind
of fresh to pull it off.
It all depends on where
your opponent's hands are.
Generally guys,
uh,
you know,
I have their hands up here.
Did see is like a triangle variation
where you reached behind the knees with a
escrip,
right?
It was a escrip.
It's like this instead of just
don't have to be fully closed.
What you say.
You don't have to be fully close to
actually go all the way up to the,
and he's wrapping
his arm around your legs that you really
cannot just so then you just go here,
go around and it's tight.
Now.
Do you want to sleep with that shit?
It works well.
This guys,
this guy is doomed.
Yeah,
but he's got,
he's got to pull.
This all has to do is keep.
This guy's going to keep
throwing punches at him.
You got a block isn't
he's going to go out?
Yeah.
That shit is terrible.
Oh,
it's old.
He's in trouble.
He's about to test ride.
This guy is tough.
It's tough arc,
but as some good he's adjusting.
Nah,
he lost it.
He lost it.
Wow.
Stacking right there.
Yeah,
it really is.
But he doesn't have it anymore.
Nope.
He's out.
Can I help him with the shoulder?
The cage is helping them to,
God dammit.
Endurance.
So much of a factor.
You know,
I'm starting to listen to
nick curse on shilling.
I know you.
You're training with him.
I'm sorry.
I listened to him more and more.
And one of the things that
he said that I was like,
wow,
that's such a controversial thing to say.
He's like,
when you're in camp for a fight you
should be doing all strength and
conditioning.
He goes,
you already know how to fight.
He's like,
you should be literally concentrating
almost entirely on your gas tank.
I was like,
wow.
Like think about that like
skill work up until fight camp,
preparing for fight camp.
How long has your mass of
strength and conditioning,
how long would the Kashi
in his book shut that too.
And I never,
I never understood it really.
It was like God,
Jill is the most important.
Gotcha.
How's your car car Joe Carter?
Joe?
I think it makes sense.
Depends what level yet.
If you're,
if your cm punk ahead and just
kind of mix everything that was,
that was,
that didn't matter.
That didn't matter.
You know this same from experiencing,
cause he doesn't have,
you know,
if,
if you're,
if you're a Joe Schilling if,
yeah.
But if you're a Joe Schilling,
you have worldclass striking and
you're in a striking contest for sure.
Getting shaped,
cause you're not gonna learn how to throw
a jab or a right high kick any better.
It's just repetitions,
right?
Yeah.
So your cardio and strength condition
makes sense if you're a young guy,
man,
I disagree.
Well I just think that that's is,
it's accurate,
but it's like he's uh,
he's like,
you should do nothing
but work on your Jujitsu.
I'm going to say you should
do anything to work on.
Your fucking striking
coach is going to work.
Like,
cause you're boxing coach to go in and
say you need to work on your skill,
your strength conditioning coach
is going to say the same thing.
And the truth is you guys work
on everything all the time.
It's all the [inaudible] because,
yeah.
But here's the other thought,
right?
When you see a guy like Damien Maia,
it like it's a one trick pony
with one fucking amazing trick.
His standup is pretty good,
you know,
that's also why he's comparing for sure.
But it's just the wonder blood.
His,
but his game is very,
it's very obvious what he's gonna do.
Cause it's not like he's mixing up things
you don't know he's going to high kick
you.
Or for a while there he was trying to
kick ass and then he changed his whole,
he changed the whole,
uh,
same thing with the soccer Robert
towards the end of his career.
He,
his strategy was always like,
I'm just going to like stand
with dudes and but maybe,
maybe take them down.
Then at the end of soccer,
rob his career,
he decided,
holy Shit,
I'd better take dudes down and choked
them out because I've been knocked out way
too many times.
But we had mine did that too.
But,
but if it,
but if my fights one Wonderboy,
he's sure it's fucking orchestra.
There's what we know that game plants
from both guys team got better at his
ground game.
I mean he got better at is overall mixed
martial arts came once a standup got
good enough where it wasn't
nervous about it anymore.
Like if you watch him fight,
his timing is excellent and his standup
defense is very good because he's,
I,
he's knowledge of when he's in trouble,
when he's not thinking,
he knows who he is.
Fine.
And that's a big part of winning
in that part of that dusty,
you know,
wanting to be a kickboxer
for a few fights.
That attitude,
I think you needed to go through that.
He needed to get through the,
because every Jujitsu guys,
biggest fear standing with someone in
the octagon and having the whole world
watched you get knocked out.
Then they got,
you know,
generally it takes a while to get to that.
That's where he's going to pass.
Yeah,
but he's a mountain.
Look at them hanging onto it.
Oh yeah.
That's tight.
But it looks pretty God damn tight.
He's all right.
Yeah.
He could have got that stop right there.
Right.
It's hard to tell what he has member
that when fucking was it to Cada,
lied and said that her
voice was choked out.
Remember that shit to in line.
Was it to cost?
That's right.
Was it him wasn't to,
to Kinda is the guy who was Yoshida.
Yoshida?
No,
no.
What do you mean kind of a ship?
And people were like,
you know,
they put a post that little
Gif of him going like,
yeah,
it was Yoshida.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yoshida.
Who was,
he wasn't an Olympic
gold medalist in judo,
some high level.
So it was a gold medalist.
He goes for the Zeke,
you'll choke.
Hoist is fine.
Hoist never,
never taps out.
And by the way,
hoist would have just
gone unconscious 100%.
100%.
And he did go unconscious.
I mean there was a fight where he
fought a Waleed ish looking at his hand.
Yeah,
but look,
he's fine.
They pull him off and he's right.
He's wide awake.
I,
you can't tell right there.
Kenya,
the rest of fucked up fucked up pieces.
Well like in the Verdun
and Travis Brown fight,
the Ref fucked up,
huh?
Oh yeah.
Pretty bad.
Like you can't have timeouts.
Yeah.
I wish I got timeouts.
The referee definitely fucked up there.
That was well played though.
I mean,
yeah,
of course you're going to do that.
Well,
I think he was probably
thinking about stopping.
I mean his finger was snapped in half,
but we couldn't tell what was going on.
Hunch though.
Yes.
For like from that Rep's perspective,
if you're,
cause sometimes your finger does and
you're going to grapple or whatever.
Your figure comes out of
the glove and you're like,
Whoa,
fixed my glove and the glove.
So like the ref didn't
know until he looked at it.
Do the x,
the rep actually
stopped it,
right?
He did.
It was good because
everyone was cool with that.
No.
Can you imagine if he
would've stopped the fight?
That would have sucked.
Who came and wanted to see the fight?
Like I let it go.
Fuck it.
No,
no.
We're good.
Everyone's good.
Who cares what the,
what the rule is?
We got to have rules.
If he had a dislocated finger,
I think everybody would
agree really quick.
If there was a button to vote,
say do we let,
do we give them a cup of fucking seconds?
His fucking finger is all,
where do you stop it?
I fuck,
I'm going to come around my joint.
You on timeout.
Let's restart.
She wished you would have stopped it.
You have to have rules.
There's no exceptions.
Do you have to have rules for
how you wanted it to stop?
I don't.
The rest of that fight was complete shit.
I wouldn't money.
Here's the thing.
Here's the deal though.
According to the rules for breezy over
doom was well within his rights to keep
punching a hundred percent so when he
punched him and referee hadn't stopped and
he was saying he was calling timeout,
but you can't really do that.
You can't do that.
Yeah.
And then the fact that they
just kept going afterwards,
he decided,
I'm just going to fight
with a broken finger,
which is admirable.
Right.
But it's like,
okay,
but,
but what would have
happened if you didn't stop?
I mean,
when he broke your finger with that punch,
he,
I mean,
how much different is that than breaking
someone's thigh with a leg kick?
When when they get hurt,
you don't stop.
You keep going.
Then if they stopped with the leg,
kick me like hold on to Holland.
Perfect.
And they're like,
how bad is it?
That's not bro.
Keep going on.
Someone breaks your forum.
That happens all the time.
It happens all the time.
Some blocks the kick and
they get their forum broken.
They stopped the fight.
You know,
they stopped the fight every time you
went into that fight with broken foot too.
But so when you're,
you know,
you catch a punch and it was one
of those weird chocolate dials,
chocolate,
Dell style overhand rights to
kind of literally comes down.
The phytic came down on his finger.
Yeah.
Was that is a freak accident?
Is it your legal,
is it illegal to break a,
your opponent's fingers?
No,
not like that.
You're not supposed to
leave or get small joints,
joint manipulation of the fingers,
but since it wasn't on purpose,
you know,
just like an eye poke.
It's not legal.
But if it happens,
you don't stop the fight.
You know,
you're just like,
did you see the eyebrows?
It was an accident.
I post accident finger,
snap off.
Look at this,
look at this.
He'll look nowhere to go.
He's got no left leg here to left.
If he could kick them
in the face right now.
Shit.
That'd be a different story.
He should be able to,
you should be didn't one FC chain.
Didn't they go back to
no kicks to the head?
Yeah,
they had a bad highlights recently.
They,
some fools getting soccer kicks bed.
Well,
did you see the Roger worked at one.
I remember
seeing one recently fucking
he gusty I love Roger.
He fought,
he fought one 70 and Roger
for one 55 in the UFC.
He fought a big Brazilian dude.
Wasn't his last fight,
his last in lots of decision,
but uh,
it was a bad knock out.
A fight synth.
Yeah.
He's had more than one fight since I
believe random veer in that same lead
kicked him mother fucker in the face too.
Damn sure.
Yeah.
Good looking kicked mother to see soccer
kicks are very different when there's a
cage because you can't get
your head out of the way.
If it's ropes,
you can get your head under the ropes and
you can kind of move and get away from
thing.
Here it is.
Boom.
I didn't show that.
Show that again Jane.
Oh,
that'll do it.
But that's a fight though.
Yeah.
Well he was already,
he was already hurt and in bad.
Some places call it a bad place to you.
Brendan,
would you allow that and
do you have UFC or keep it?
I would not keep it the way it is
unless you hate Bradington sponsors.
I totally allowed.
Right,
totally lost.
The dude's bent over heroin.
A this guy used to drop knees
from north south all the time.
Yeah.
Oh,
that was the best and it changed.
It changed the way that that occurred.
It changes it completely.
Well,
here's the thing.
Well the new rule is a down fighter
is four points on the ground.
Not Three points in there like that.
So if you have a guy on the
ground and he is covering,
covering up and the turtle,
all you have to do is
hold onto one of his arms.
You pick one of his arms off the
ground and at least by my definition,
you could start kicking them
and need them in the face.
Right.
If you can't,
if you can't hit a down deponent
because of Tylenol polar.
Yeah.
You just take one off,
pick one up and you start blasting him.
Or if you guys were fucking
knees now 22 feet or like too,
is that for,
cause it's got two feet.
Two knees.
Yeah,
he is it,
is that a downed opponent?
Like how,
what,
what do you can send me a
knee is the death count,
but two knees if you're
on your knees like,
okay,
so if a,
if a guy's down,
right?
Once his handcuffs off the ground,
that's when it's legal.
But his knees are on the ground.
Still not legal.
Right.
Is that how you're still not legal?
Right?
Yeah,
that's right.
But if a guy,
so if a guy with the new rules,
if a guy had his feet flat on the ground
and he was touching the ground with two
hands and you just
pulled one of those arms,
you can do whatever the fuck you want.
Yep.
Correct.
Hmm.
That's,
that'd be some new training or
on your knees down opponent.
I think when both fighters
are on the ground,
you should be allowed to kick to the
head because I think if a guy can upkick
you for the bottom bullshit,
you should totally,
like when someone's going for an arm bar,
you should be able to,
I'll kick the fuck out of their face like,
why are you allowed to defend yourself?
Right?
Bottom or me coming at you,
but I can't strike you at the end.
It gives you all this other bullshit.
It gives you an unrealistic sense of
what's real and not real on the ground
because there's a lot of stuff that
goes on the ground and the ground.
That wouldn't happen if the guy
could just kick you in the face,
right?
Because if you're lying
in a weird position,
the guy just blasting shins to your face,
you're going to stop what you're doing
and have to readjust and you're going to
have to make that,
make that a part of the equation.
You're going to have to prepare
for that totally downward elbows,
shit on the ground,
a stupid whore.
It's total bullshit.
It makes no sense on the ground.
You may think they brought it up if they
were going to make that rule about the
ice breaking or whatever the
fuck their reasoning was.
If I'm standing up and when I do that,
then okay,
yeah,
on your knees,
you're not going to
have any power to like,
it's not like you're a
dangerous and it's fighting.
It's no more dangerous than anything else.
I mean it's a,
it's a weapon.
If there was an argument allow,
but if everyone collectively
says hell fucking no,
then yes.
Those are the ones that you,
I mean,
it's fighting.
We want to,
yeah,
I mean,
don't you think the UFC represents or is,
uh,
represents what,
what true fighting really is 100%.
It should,
it should.
It's the,
should the should be that still,
dude,
I think we should get rid of the cage.
I think they should hold it in a
space the size of a basketball arena.
Goddammit.
And she'd be like a basketball floor and
there should be no fucking cage and I,
and they just run for what I think.
Okay.
If I'm the king of the world and uh,
I get to make the news DFC,
we get rid of the gloves,
no gloves,
no hand tapes.
That's all bullshit.
And to my show and an Indian reservation,
you could do anything you want.
That's what I'm saying.
What about,
what about gloves?
Well,
you eye gouge.
Immediate deduction of 1.1 immediate too.
I gouges you're out Ted
budding wait is over.
If you did that on the Indian reservation
budding should be in an arm bar.
Can I bite your ankle to get it off by
writing an eye poking.
And the only thing is the thing
about buying about ball sheets,
the biting is super dangerous as
far as bacteria and stuff like that.
I want dude's dying on my show staff
and but,
but blinding and shit.
Look,
we know we can poke
each other in the eyes.
So this is,
this is not fighting.
That's just a green can't hit the,
can't reach into my package
and grabbed my hockey and Dick.
Dick don't touch the hot grill.
No pet kicks to the back of the head.
Legal elbows to the back of head,
elbows to the back of the head when
you don't even need rear naked choke.
So once they allow the elbows,
legal,
all that past soccer kicks,
stomps,
soccer,
kicks legal,
we'll do it.
No cage fighting.
Chip RF,
start start young league,
that basketball,
this fucking thing.
And you have a basketball
court for basketball and
basketball is boring as fuck.
How about that Ben?
So he got that big ass place for football.
Look at giant space.
How about two dudes meet in the
middle of a fucking football arena?
How about that site and go crazy.
No problem with the basketball arena.
The problem with the basketball arena is
you're going to have to like change all
these other rules to force them to fight.
Exactly.
Going to have to make yellow cards.
You have to make all that shit because
you let the public decide even sparring
and an open room.
Where does it?
Big Mat.
One guy doesn't want to fucking spar
and just walking around the room chasing
good.
Let the 50,000 people that
would come to my shows is boom.
Here's another thing I'm doing.
This is another thing I do
and if I'm king of the world,
I bring Ben her into the UFC immediately.
I agree.
That's a disgrace.
Everybody in the car golf,
he's sunned him.
Took him down,
man.
The fuck you wanted let,
let's just go,
let's just cover this real quick.
You'll have cm punk fight,
but not Ben asked.
Oh yeah,
the UFC world.
Are we living?
What are you talking about?
Point.
Very good point.
That's a headline right there.
1 billion people watch him.
See what was day 100,000 star.
He made a ton of money,
made a half a million dollars on paper
that would they what they show and people
were complaining about it and like,
do you have any eyes that
guy brought to that show?
Yes,
he's worth it.
Money.
He's a very,
very famous guy and I think
he handled it really well.
Like as far as like his post
fight speech is interview the way,
talked about it.
He handled it really.
He gave Micky Gall we're a weird
speech to him after it was over.
But you've also got a bailout.
You gotta believe in yourself
the way I believe in myself,
bitch,
I just speak to you just got to really
want to get my advice from you also want
it to WWE mode right away,
right?
He's,
that's his world,
man.
This is a,
this is really his first venture into
reality and you know what I mean?
You go out there and you
think everything's gonna go
great cause it's gone great
your whole life with no competition
and then all of a sudden your first
competition is in the UFC.
Wow.
Was he going to go any other way?
It's insane.
How's it going to be liked it.
Maybe he was.
He says he did.
Eh,
there's no way they live to fight again.
There's no way hit.
People were like,
fuck that.
I'm not going to go through them with my
family there and he could fight again.
He could totally find a seat.
Not In the UFC.
He's got to fight as an amateur show.
He just got to learn.
He ruined that shot.
You can't find them once you fight pro,
you can't fight amateur.
Oh,
is that how it works?
There's no Glenn,
you can fight pro,
but listen,
you just got to fight people that
are of the same ability as you.
People that are learning,
you know what they should do.
You should go on like a regional
circuit and fight fight.
Guys with similar experience have a whole
documentary like getting back to the
UFC and fucking sell out.
They dropped the cm punk.
What's his real name?
Phil Brooks.
You're Phil Brooks.
Motherfucker dropped the cm punk.
That's,
I like keeping it because he had
that name before he came to WWE.
That was his name.
That's why he owns it.
That's why he's allowed to use it still
and everybody knows him as that like
it's a smart move.
As far as like marketing,
I think that guy could still go on
the regional shirt circuit and fight.
People that are just starting out,
they're just starting out just like
him and he could probably become like a
competent fighter,
a competent professional fighter,
but that's something
that takes a long time.
It's not like he has any handicaps.
I love he his will if he has a will and
he has the desire because he enjoys it.
Apparently if he has a will and he has
a desire and he wants to test himself,
I firmly believe that that guy could
go and become a competent professional
fighter.
No,
I didn't say that.
I said a competent professional fighter.
I think he's a smart guy.
I think he's a tough guy.
I just think this was his
first real combat sports
experience and I don't think,
I think that's it.
I think they did them a disservice.
Granted he made whatever,
some figures after paper you bonus.
I just don't think a day did them a
disservice if he actually wanted to pursue
this as a career.
Dana,
the commission has
coaches Swintt listen man,
you got to take the necessary steps
like ruin else did because there's no
turning back.
Once you go to the UFC man,
it's kind of you're in and out brother.
Well you know guys have come back.
They've gone to other organizations had
combat 38 with no skills transfer 10
years.
It's not likely.
It's not likely,
but it's also not likely that you become
a professional fighter at 37 as well.
These none of these things are likely,
but there's no worries about that though,
right?
Well,
most people were doing something else
by the time the 38 and it's not their
career path.
You know,
it's,
it's a very rare that someone decides
to go into that at such a late stage of
life.
But look,
if he's in good shape
and he's a healthy guy,
what what he needs to do
is if he wants to learn,
just train all the time,
train all the time and take your time
in getting involved in competition again
because you,
you,
you know,
you can't get an argument with
someone when you only know four words.
Yeah,
I liked the guest.
It's not going to work.
Right.
And it's the same thing as a fight.
He's a fighting this kid who I
watched Mickey Golf fight in the UFC,
his first five.
I'm like,
this fucking kid is good.
What can we take that guy's back,
guys.
Thanks.
[inaudible] like Micky Gall
has some serious work to
do as well in that division
is a long ways to go.
But,
and he dismantled cm punk,
these other jet brown belt,
Brown belt.
But he still has,
if you look the the spectrum
of that division at me,
he has a lot of work that of
course it's an insane division,
but he's still very new.
Well that was kind of what
cm punk was saying to him.
Cause he was saying that he didn't belong
in the UFC and the only reason why he
was in the UFC was to fight a cm punk.
He was kind of saying that,
but what the kid's doing is being smart.
He's just self deprecating.
He's a smart fucking kid.
I like,
I would call about sage.
Northcutt said he was corny.
It was really good.
Really good job.
[inaudible]
speech.
Oh all fuck.
Yeah.
And you know what's,
what's fucking the sage
have a fight coming up.
I Dunno dude.
That's the heartthrob fight.
Those two,
couple,
one,
two acuities couple
dime pieces going at it.
I don't know what Micky Gall drives.
So hopefully something cool.
Yeah.
Strictly used to drive American
and then Shit on Cobra.
Driving to a Japanese car.
Pick him up.
America gets after him.
Yay.
I didn't even know that
fell or it's got a jackpot.
An HR hooked him up.
Trump.
Yeah.
Someone's got to get them up
and not even like a corvette,
like a customer.
Shelby Bro Mustang.
Mustang.
The new one.
New One.
Just shits on them.
Honk and narrow back in the action.
Kenny Robertson.
This is a good fight.
Any Robertson slick,
however,
Kenny Robinson is one that
hit that weird leg lock.
Remember that weird leg
lock he got from a scramble?
It was a real strange knee bar.
I was like,
dude,
I don't think I've seen
one of those before.
I don't remember why,
but I'm trying to,
yeah,
I'm trying to remember how he hit it.
He hit about a,
he thought Ben Saunders.
Who the fuck is that?
Yeah,
that's just Kenny Robinson talking.
Why did they have a solid
rustler good Jujitsu?
He's,
he's no joke,
man.
Kenny Kenny Roberts is very smart.
I'll fight him and Ben Saunders.
That was tough.
Yeah.
Three hard rounds do hop out.
Uh,
how about your boy?
Chill.
Sewn in Sanibel tour.
Good move.
Right move for him.
Listen man,
I hope Shane Carwyn does it too.
Not necessarily that.
I hope Shane doesn't sign with the UFC.
I hope you signs where
he gets the best deal.
100% but I think it's good
to have guys like Rory.
It's good to have like legit
worldclass fighters over there.
I like it.
I think competition is
good for everything.
It's good for everybody.
It elevates everybody everywhere.
Like with,
with jail.
It was a little like last night I
was watching a Bella torn that child.
Do you know he does his
whole gangster shit talking.
Remember he hasn't been around in a while.
So when you used to like a fricking Conor
McGregor shit talking [inaudible] it
was like hot tub time machine.
Like we like it.
It was a little old
school and I talked to,
I love chili like a bro.
I fucking love jail,
but I was like [inaudible] this is Tom.
This is old school.
It's certainly seemed prepared.
Yes,
I did it.
It was always like,
it was more,
it was natural,
but also there's no,
like he's calling out teat or tease,
you know,
and there's like no real animosity.
And then Tito tweet back like,
I'm going to,
I'm going to show you the bad guy's girl.
God dammit.
We got to 40 year olds
talking shit on Twitter,
silence.
And I looked and I fucking love Jen and I,
I,
I love to see him fight but seeing
his shit talking compared to Connor's,
it's like,
well Connor took that
torch and ran with it.
Yeah.
I had dinner the other night.
Would Maynard from tool?
Mainer Keenan is a buddy of mine and uh,
he's uh,
he's in Jujitsu,
he's a purple belt,
loves Jujitsu,
loves MMA.
And we were talking about
the UFC and he goes,
God damn it,
why the fuck is it becoming a WWE?
He goes,
this is making me sad.
Cause it's like everybody's trying to
be Connor Mcgregor and they're coming up
with these corny fucking pre-fight promos.
It's tough.
He's like,
aw,
it makes me just cause he's,
you know,
he's just a fucking super
smart genius dude here.
Stuff doesn't he loves,
he loves martial arts.
So when he sees non martial
artists type behavior,
like pro wrestling type behavior and my,
if they just trying to sell themselves,
he should tell Shawn was talking about,
he goes,
I just beat the fucking
number two container.
I'm ranked number one.
Give me the fucking rematch.
What do I gotta do?
He goes,
I'm not a shit talker.
I'm not going to do that.
I'll tell you I'm not finding one.
But then I went,
I don't know if it's enough.
Is there any way can watch like ric flair
or some shit and just pick up a couple
of,
come on.
You just pick up a few things like watch
macho man and just start spitting some
game online.
It's sports entertainment,
but the thing is you can't,
like Connor is that guy.
That's him.
That's how he talks all the time.
He's a sharp shit talker from Ireland and
he knows how to fight and he knows how
to talk.
And it's an unusual combination.
Yes.
Most guys don't know how to
talk that know how to fight.
And most guys who know how to
talk don't know how to fight.
Correct.
When do,
you could talk that much
shit and fight that.
Well,
you're a unicorn.
he's a unicorn also.
He,
he can fight the mind,
fucking see puts on dudes
because he can talk so much shit.
The love of all those
people that are behind them,
all those Irish people and then the mind
fucking from them screaming at you all
the time,
the entire,
you know,
six weeks up until the fight and then
the shit that he says about you and the
fact that he might very well sleep.
You could mine my very well dropped out
nuclear left hand on your face route.
Rumor is Eddie Alvarez in him.
Tangoing uh,
and maybe a little
something that I was shy.
Hey,
just give me an eyebrow
outside Madison Square Garden.
If it was a mute,
if it was a rumor.
There's the,
there's the Kenny Robertson,
a arm bar or leg lock.
He took it from the back.
That's what it was.
Oh yeah.
Crazy,
right?
Yeah,
I remember that.
Yeah.
Motherfuckers stretched out.
See that shit wouldn't work with me.
[inaudible] got rolling.
Carnero who's just a black
belt really on the ground.
It's like forever.
Yeah.
Carneros nasty.
Going to have a hard time.
Her did,
sir.
His,
his,
uh,
Jujitsu is very nasty.
Very nasty.
Yeah.
It's,
it's an interesting fight,
man.
That's all with the headhunter Connor.
Yeah.
If it happens,
if allegedly acid square garden,
if it happens in a couple of months,
maybe that's gonna happen.
It's gonna happen.
But if it does happen,
uh,
that might happen.
Joe and he can grapple
for freaking graphical,
forgetting I'm a can.
Russell's a fucking grinder
and whatever endurance issues,
Connor,
it may have he better eye on those fuckers
out before you go to town with that
guy.
You know,
I'm the biggest Conor
McGregor fan on the planet.
I love that guy.
But looking at his potential
opponents at one 55 and it's 70,
it's like,
fuck man,
it,
it doesn't look pretty.
And Eddies of rough matchup for him,
it's probably easiest,
but I don't think it's an easy one at all.
I'm saying,
I'm saying that 55,
they're all fucking tough.
They are all top stylistically.
If you know you're like,
God damn,
I Guess Eddie's the best matchup.
I don't see it a lot because
he's on a fucking nightmare,
I don't think is the best match up at all.
Who would you say is,
well,
first of all,
any Eddie's known for having a chat.
It's known for having a Chin and known
for being able to bounce back from
getting hurt.
He's got massive heart
and he fights at his best.
When the chips were on the line,
like in the dos Anjos fight,
nobody gave him a shot and that fight,
who gave him the shot in that fight?
He was probably like,
uh,
at least two to one underdog.
Right?
For sure.
Going into that fight with a dominant
champion at Hoffeld Dosantos so just got
done stop and cowboys Serone in
the first round working Nate Diaz,
you know,
beating the shit out at
pedes for five rounds.
You're looking at dos sign,
just going,
Holy Shit,
this guy might be able to run
this division for a long time.
And Alvarez clips him and he looked
real good before he clipped him.
He had some sleepless nights before.
Then we had real Eddie
Alvarez for until that fight.
You're like,
that's the fucking belt door.
That's the fucking free
agent that we want.
And See Melendez fight and the
Pettis fight you like Jesus.
Scott's better.
You know it's part of it
is he's gotten better.
Well the UFC jitters or are real.
So no matter if you have
30 fights are apparently,
if you have zero cm punk,
those jitters are real.
Where is he training now?
Who?
Eddie Alvarez.
He with your board?
Mark Henry with Mark Henry.
That's a big Frankie Edgar
and he's wrestling at Rutgers.
He's a monster man telling you.
Mark Henry is a mother there.
Barboza they've all those guys.
But you look at the top
five and for Connor.
It's fucking tough man.
It is tough.
But I think that's part of the
reason why Eddie looks so good now.
He looks so fucking sharp.
You can't discount the fact
he's trained with Barboza.
He's tranquil.
Frankie Edgar and he's absorbing from
Henry is the mastermind of Mark Henry.
He's a bad motherfucker,
dude.
He's the the most slept
on trainer marketing.
I know most slept on street doesn't
want to be in the limelight and he hates
that stuff.
But if he was more outspoken,
I mean Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
it'd be all over.
Rashad pulled me aside at one of the
umcs and was just going on and on about
what a bad mother fucker.
Never seen anything like him.
And he still checks in on me all the time.
I don't fight anymore.
I worked with him for May two or
three weeks and he would have,
I'm telling you man,
like a path like this in his basement.
I had sores on my feet
because I was barefoot and in
his basement doing footwork
nonstop.
He had notes for fucking days like,
uh,
like he's obsessed with it.
Yeah.
He's,
he's brilliant.
Clearly on the spectrum makes the best
pizza in fucking New Jersey in the world
too.
I heard heard,
is this a silly cook?
What?
God,
I'm a fungus pizzas off and that,
that's a place where
pizzas like highly praise.
Like you gotta you gotta come with some
real pizza if you want to make a living
in New Jersey.
Yeah.
Catching up world champions
and making mean espe pizzas.
I don't think Eddie's,
uh,
I don't think that's an easy fight.
I don't think [inaudible] at
one 50 that's what I'm saying.
I'm saying if you looked
at those top five,
none of them are easy at all.
Like it.
The future doesn't look great
at 55 I don't want to see,
I don't,
I can't say that either because
you don't get that til five.
Tell me,
tell me the best match.
We'll,
Nate is clearly one of the best.
Nate's clearly one of the best 155 pounds.
Diaz.
Yes,
he's,
he's better at 55 and [inaudible] 70.
Yeah.
Well seventies not really fighting
at 70 mean he fought Rory at 70.
He fought.
So I'm saying fuck Conor at
70 and that was a tough out.
They did that because that's what they
did the first time when he took the fight
last minute notice,
he wanted to have the
exact same corrections.
That's why Conor did it at 70 again,
but Nate's of one 50 fiver and at one
55 like when he fought Michael Johnson,
when he's shredded,
he looked at its best.
Right.
He's up better.
Nate Dhea.
And if you see the Nate Diaz that beat,
you know Michael Johnson if 55 he's one
of the best fighters in that division
for sure.
Hands Down,
not even close.
So Connor just beat him.
I mean obviously a very close fight,
very close decision.
But I think,
I think it was probably a fair decision.
I have to go over it and score it.
I haven't gone over it and scored it.
It was,
it was,
it was a fair decision.
I mean it was,
I don't think anyone lost in that fight.
But yeah,
going to the judges.
I did have Connor slightly
edging that fight.
I think you,
you look at the damage done,
he did more damage,
you know,
he dropped Nate.
You know what makes sense about that?
I saw at the grocery store randomly and
he was saying that he was falling on
purpose to dupe Connor and he goes,
I knew the first two rounds,
three rounds are going to be,
he's so fast as me,
tough.
So when he hit me,
the plan was to fall down
to get him to false down,
to follow me down.
He goes,
cause I couldn't take him down.
So the plan was given
to follow me down there.
Ooh,
that's interesting.
That's a risky game plan.
That's what that,
that's from the horse's mouth,
that,
that's one of those,
is that one of those I
meant to do that things.
I don't know.
I don't know Nate.
He has enough to be like you serious
as the pee wee Herman defense.
Either way.
I meant to do that,
huh?
Yeah.
Yeah,
me either way.
Nate's one of the best in the world and
there's a more of a nightmare at 55 is
I'm trying to get to,
yeah,
I agree.
He's a tougher fight at 55 I mean,
I think you fight better
when he's lighter.
You know,
it's probably sucks to get down there,
but your lighter and you
move faster is better.
Cardio is going to be a good fight,
man.
This will be a good fight.
Kenny Robertson and Hong Kong narrow.
I'm going to watch 30 seconds with
a nice knee to the body there.
So I think what I love about Connor is it,
that's what he wants to do.
I don't think he could make 45 anymore.
I mean either there's
camp says he can either.
It's just too hard to match so bad.
He has the 45 belt.
He just beat Nate at 70 then let's
say he Merck's Eddie Alvarez,
so he's the one 45 one 55 champ.
What then what do you do?
I kind of want to see him rematch.
All though though I kind
of do a kind of honesty.
Don't fight again at 45 it nothing that
when they say it's too tough for him now
and stuff,
corneal got their back.
This is no good.
Ooh,
I like high butterflies.
That back leg on Max took
it that way to the back.
Ooh,
look at that.
Squeeze.
That's nice control.
I think there's better fight at
45 when you think of all though.
Max Holloway Shit.
Oh,
Kenny.
Good job.
Recovering.
Still still babbling.
Oh,
he goes deep half.
Oh Shit.
Go narrow.
Oh,
Kimmy Robertson with that wrestling.
Very nice.
Nice escape.
Kenny Roberts has got
some weird hand movements.
He does right before he punches.
You know,
he like key let's Danish.
Yeah.
He lets his hands go limp and her around.
I wonder if he does that on purpose.
So when there's a strategy behind that,
like maybe to remind
himself to fight loose.
Hmm.
Or maybe it's just a tick.
Yeah.
Maybe it was like,
oh,
this twitches
on his hands when he was fun.
Yeah.
For relax.
I can relax.
Yeah.
Pancreas.
That's so easy said than done.
Especially when you're finding someone
that just constantly puts pressure on
you.
Okay.
But that,
going back to that cardio thing,
man,
when two guys are skillfully
like very similar,
but one guy's just got some stupendous
Marv Marinovich style gas tank and he
knows how to fight,
but now he's just got this unbelievable
gas tank talking about that Cain
Velasquez.
Yeah.
Like,
well,
Kane knows how to fight obviously,
but with the scariest thing
about Kane is the volume he puts
cardio's at heavyweight.
It's insane,
dude.
You tell me,
you tell me a better heavyweight match
up besides maybe Uber reman Brock besides
steep avers Kane.
That's the fucking fight of the century,
son.
It's amazing.
Besides a roid to the Dick Overeem
versa judge juiced up Brock,
which I was calling for.
I was like,
Oh hell yeah,
that was sick.
But uh,
uh,
supplement free cane for something free.
Steep a sign me up.
Yeah,
it's a great fight.
They're very similar man.
Steve Bay.
So gangster out of the two,
which was rather see the to city to city.
I'm not trying,
no,
not,
not in 2016 or 2017.
I'm trying to see juiced up
rain verse juiced up Brock.
Now.
Well,
if they hadn't had that first fight,
I would you bring them back
to the same place they were.
Same place they were at the time.
I agree.
That first fight in the UFC,
you know what,
Brock making a comeback
after losing his title.
I disagree.
Steve Avers Keynes,
the fucking fine.
You don't have to disagree.
We just have,
we want different things out of
this world would be a disagreement.
I want nothing wrong with that.
I want you city
to city on a football field.
How I'm to
on a football field,
I think the cage is an artificial boundary
and I think it plays a big factor in
movement and a big factor in the fight.
I mean how much fucking
foot work do you need?
25 foot or 30 foot came
as if they have 30 feats.
A big case
you could have the cage the way it is.
Where did they start to have a border
where if you pass that border you've got
to get back inside.
So the cage never becomes a factor.
So like if you're fighting and you take
a guy down and he know his ass scoots
outside of the,
the,
the boundary line,
but there's still,
you know,
50 feet in any one direction.
If someone's driving forward,
you take that guy,
you move into the middle of the cage or
the middle of the mat and you assume the
same position.
That's not hard to do.
They did that in pride all day long.
They could do that.
They have replaced,
they can see exactly
where it guy was set up.
The referee holds on,
I'm ready,
set,
fight,
and you go back to fighting again.
That way there's never any artificial
cage that's in the way that helps you get
back up to your feet.
Everybody would have way harder,
way harder time getting back up to
their feet if there was no cage.
If you couldn't wall walk,
it's a big guy that take Tatum.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The dropdown.
Scoop your hands together
because the guy can't move.
He can't keep backing
up and pummeling under,
but it's hard to take guys down when
they're against the fence and they're just
her at the fence.
The two part to that,
right.
If the fence wasn't there,
they'd get you down.
Easy a check.
It's a factor.
The cage is a fact.
I liked that factor.
It's part of the game.
Yeah,
me too.
There needs to be board fence,
wrestling sport.
Like I don't watch Nascar Elevator,
funny guy down and the guys got to use
the fence.
I have to get taken down.
You got to like a minute to
take him down or something.
The guys that get really good at
that translate to MMA a lot better.
Right?
Yeah.
Maybe.
I think that we would be better
off though if it wasn't a factor,
but just think that's not going to happen.
We just think it's too late for that.
Thinks what I think.
I think fighting as a sport should be
as pure as possible and it's not as pure
as possible.
I think kicks on the
ground soccer kick stomps.
No cage,
no gloves about mouthpiece.
Yeah.
Yes.
Mouthpieces didn't have you get punched.
It's going to go straight
through your fucking lips,
your teeth go through your and stuff.
Bacteria [inaudible] staff.
I could see it coming now.
He could get staff on your knuckles.
So that is a good point because when
guys punch guys with bare teeth,
like in street fights,
they get staff all the times.
More common than you'd think.
It's real dangerous if you
don't treat it just broke.
My hand falls off gang green and shit.
Ooh,
that's nasty.
Human mouth is gross,
but just between the cage and
the soccer kicks on the ground,
how the different the sport
would evolve in five years.
It would change how different kicks in
the ground techniques you guys would be
using.
Everything that you'd be doing
kicks on the ground to the face.
They should already do combos where a
guy's mounted like Vander light used to
do.
He'd get them out,
throw a couple punches,
then stand up and just stop and walk away.
That's a combo,
right?
If a guy should can upkick you,
you should be able to stomp him.
Hundred percent,
hundred percent changes
the game of Jujitsu,
like tremendously elbows
to the back of the head.
Dude,
you better make a move quick.
You can't date turtled up.
Turn on was,
you should be able to fuck
a dude up for Tertullian.
How many dudes just get
broken by that though.
How many careers get caught short?
You see it coming and like
after a while the rep would go,
you know if you do this can
hold it for three seconds.
And the guy didn't move.
He stopped the fight.
You know what?
I have to connect
Gary Goodrich and that was
that one of his page or fights.
He got them in the fucking crucifix.
Just doubled.
That was probably the
worst Nacada version.
I was thinking when Gary Goodrich grabbed
the guy's Dick crushed the Pedro dude
in Brazil.
He reached into his pants and grabbed
his dick and balls and crushed,
crushed
peanut butter them.
They actually happen.
Yeah,
there's no rules.
There's no rules.
Zero sweaty and shit.
Just put it's rest of nuts.
Brazilians like wearing
those pro wrestling briefs.
Gary.
Good
vicious growing attacks.
Yeah.
Damn,
Jamie's good.
That's after the fight is trying to,
hey man,
you know I'm just doing my phone.
Sorry about that thing.
Crabs are like the squoze
your balls and Dick.
Yeah,
that's not good.
So Kenny Robertson on top
horn Carnero on the bottom,
looking for the arm triangle,
not pulling it off.
It's going to be hard to do anything
excited for Uriah Hall Brunson.
Me Too.
He's coming after Eddie in this position.
Right?
You,
you want to,
you want an under hook on that
side right there on the bottom.
It has the half guard bottom
wants to get the under hook.
Obviously the guy on top on her
to keep that under hook and keep that
head and arm and Cornell went right to us.
He knows what he's doing.
Yeah,
you went right to it.
Went right to that again.
The Cook,
he's not planned.
It's pretty definitely.
Yeah.
He's super talented.
Super talented.
I was gonna say Alex Davis,
you've got to make that move.
Was telling me about rolling with them.
Went on.
What a nightmare at night.
Yeah.
I've got to get in there and go.
He's got to go on.
This is the difference.
That change is straight grappling and
grapple and a dude like Kenny Robertson's
a lot of punch you in the face,
elbow you in the face changes everything.
Oh,
there it goes.
Let's go to the leg.
Oh Shit.
Oh,
can I do it all has Slippy slips
every night for that paypal.
He's mounted bell.
Oh,
good.
Shrimp Butterfly.
Now,
now this is where our rubber
guard comes into play.
Left,
right arm pinned to the mat.
I'm not sure he has the
flexibility to play right,
but,
but if he could to good place for it,
that Eddie knowledge,
he could,
but he's a friend of mine,
but
they're not working for him
or maybe he never went to it.
That flexibility son
Joe Rubber Guard play.
They go to a right away.
Like you could just tell that
he's trying to set it off off of
risk control and the left arm.
Nothing wrong with that.
As long as you keep that clench,
it's keeping that right arm tight.
Oh look at this.
Good adjust.
Oh look what he's doing there.
Their style.
That's like a,
a rat guard right there.
There's a guard called rat garden.
He's the rest.
Go add it up.
Wrap it up.
Pass that elbow.
We're trying to go past that right elbow,
but he's not sure how to commit.
Oh God.
Am I doing dance?
Oh my God.
That was amazing.
Successful wrap there.
Yeah,
I gotta look into that and he
goes into a mounted triangle.
He looked hurt too.
Yeah,
that's face did not fit it.
Look Fun Dude.
I need to learn that rat guard is
actually the guy who made it up.
I forget his name.
Destination Believer.
But anyways,
it's,
he's been doing it for like now 10 years
now and he always called it a rubber
guard for guys that have no flexibility.
Cause I think he had an accident.
He had an accident at hips.
All fucked up stuff with
Rohan was doing right there.
That's legit shit.
It worked.
I mean,
look what it did.
It changed the teacher telling me too.
It's real.
Those are times where I'm like,
I dunno,
he's looking for that.
I'm triangle.
Look at that.
I was going to try and go for a on now,
but I got it right there.
That's the master rat.
Jamie needs a raise.
God Damn Jamie is on the ball.
God Damn fucking extra fuck man.
Coffee Son.
But now he turns it off.
Now I take back what I said.
So this is a,
this is rat guard so that it's
second round has got the grip down.
Hi Rat was,
it sounds very rat.
Like listen.
Um,
I have actually a damaged leg.
So you notice I had certain
angles I can't play in this.
I developed the light guard
as an alternative to the
rubber guard because I have
paralysis in my life.
So what I'm going to
do is most people play.
Look,
there's no way we're watching this whole
thing just while we're in the middle,
just troll.
Just the first thing he
does the first thing,
if you hate race,
watched,
watch.
Yeah.
Just that first little controlling show.
A whole rack.
Yeah.
Video and my legs and put my hand on
his year and push as if I'm going for
getting,
however,
I'm not going for you to grabbing my
Shin here or am my leg under here.
That's exactly what he was doing.
Yeah.
And then he swept them with it,
right?
I go here.
They swept in with and he
turned it into a triangle.
[inaudible] elbow down.
Okay,
here we go.
Round three powerful rat pastor.
Oh Shit.
That's going to blow up now.
That's interesting.
How Long Carnero on the ball recognizing
all sorts of different moves.
That's one of the most important
things about your ditzy,
right?
Being able to understand all
the new shit that's going on.
Yeah.
I never went to it.
I never bothered playing it only
because I do have the flexibility.
I didn't need to do that,
but fuck it seems like
an interesting option.
Sold.
No.
Yeah,
I'm all over it now.
I see Cornell is going
to be super nervous now.
I mean Robertson's gotta be super nervous
now being reversed in a position like
that.
Put it in a bag is really good
and he's got good wrestling so,
oh that was all kind of,
oh Riverside,
thank goodness.
Nice exchange.
Mice Robertson is,
oh see this verdict by
get that cardio ups.
I would like to know
like what is the barrier?
Very best method to prepare.
I would really like to know,
like is it possible that Hong Carnero
could have done something different and
could be like mighty mouse here in this
third round or is it simply a function
of being 170 pounds being a bigger man,
cutting the way down.
Is it I,
I really,
I would,
I'm sure genetics or something
to do with it for sure.
I just want to,
I always want you to tell your body to
gas and I mean that's what real sprinting
is to train your body to gas and
recovering gas recovery on a clock.
Gas Recovery,
gas recover.
So you do it so much so you
could be fucking dead tired
and the match and you're
like,
I'm going to recover in about 20 seconds.
The fights are so train your body,
the nerve,
she can't.
It's tough to train it to a t.
It is little things.
It was a perfect answer.
It's there's,
I mean there may be,
but it's about optimization like right.
How could you take a guy,
like whether it's Carnero Oh shit,
beautiful left hook or anybody,
any fighter for that matter and train
them physically to like a perfect state,
like turn Woodley and a
fucking Demetrius Johnson.
Yeah,
but will you wouldn't,
I mean obviously Johnson doesn't have
the kind of horsepower the Woodley has
either.
When you have
a huge part of it,
like the vehicle,
the vessel you're messing with,
you can only do so much.
What I did was swim sprints.
And what I liked about
that is first of all,
I hate running,
but when you're doing swim sprints,
no matter how exhausted you get,
like give you 20 of them or whatever,
that's what I was doing.
Uh,
no matter how exhausted you get at 14,
15 and 16,
when you're sprinting across the pool,
you're,
your breathing has to be perfect.
So there's all this chaos going on
in your head and you're sprinting.
You're breathing has to be
perfectly swallow water.
So that,
that's the beauty.
And then there's,
you know,
the impact,
there's no impact.
It's a natural movement.
And,
uh,
it,
it makes you focus when you
focus on your breathing,
when you know you're your worst possible.
I think also for Jujitsu it's really
good because it's not just leg dependent
because when you're running,
it's your arms rarely get tired.
What's getting tired or your
legs like almost only your legs,
your lungs and your legs.
Your arms are obviously playing
a park because you're pumping,
your arms are moving,
but they're not getting nearly
as tired as your fucking legs.
Yeah.
When you're swimming,
your arms get tired as fuck.
Yeah.
Tiredness to me.
And if you wear flippers,
I bet your legs get even more work.
Right.
Because all the resistance to do
flippers on the hands to their hands.
Maurice doggy paddle.
You don't even have to swim.
You just have to sprint,
you know,
and yeah.
Yeah.
That's some bullshit.
You really,
you really need to get,
if,
if you want to do it right and get it
with a swim coach so he can get efficient
and learn how to really do it.
Ken Robinson coming on strong here.
Nice Jab my car.
Narrow.
You can do it on your own.
You don't need a trainer.
The cool thing about swimming is if,
if you do it on a clock where every
time the clock hits 12 you sprint and
however it takes you to a long to get
it across the pool could be 25% gains.
It can be 23 seconds,
27 seconds.
You rest until that clock hits 12 again.
So yeah,
so you ended up doing is you don't
need anybody to tell you to push your
sprinting for that rest time.
It's an,
it's a mind fuck.
That's the beauty of the sprints and
the water to you're sprinting to rest.
Cause you know,
if you fuck up and you just like
kind of give up halfway through,
you're gonna fuck up the rotation.
The clock.
Now you fucked your whole system up there.
I love swimming.
You got to do that 20 times across like,
you know,
pulled it like you got a 24 hour fitness.
Um,
it's like a 20 yard pool.
20 I dunno,
maybe 39 the ocean.
If you're gangster,
son,
barn,
Carneros running out of gas
here in the heart and the ocean.
Like where do you stop
and where do you go?
I'm stopping.
You got to have a clear
start and stop points.
Yeah.
Or You just doing it for time.
Exactly.
Do it different.
That's a whole different scenario.
This is just for pure sprinting.
Yeah,
but you're doing off time to,
it's the 12 right?
Did they make heart rate
monitors that work in the ocean?
I Dunno.
I I bought the new fucking iPhone seven
because I thought it could go to the
ocean for this reason.
Then I find out you can't go in the
ocean with the iPhone seven doesn't go in
the ocean.
Well that's assault though.
Right?
Salt is
really bad.
Now they say the water,
like even if you drop in fresh water,
you have like a couple minutes
to flux are below 30 minutes.
It's like 30 minutes at
nine feet before cardio.
Cardio must be nuts.
Punch people in the face.
Smoked cigarettes.
You got a big,
you got a big fight coming up
with a,
I do a lot of running and then we expect,
yeah.
Uh,
how do you set it up?
Like you don't just go jog,
I'll jog at least like three days a week
and I'm like three to five miles and
then uh,
I'll do sprints like I used to do.
Like how do you do your sprint
one mile sprint twice a week.
A full mile.
It's hard as you can go and I
would try to keep track of that.
Touch your time.
So my fastest time ever,
which I think is still on my Instagram
was like a five 28 or something like
that's rolling.
Have you ever had somebody in the car
like next to me yelling at me and like
keeping me motivated all the time and
just going to have every gas been a fight
where you lost because
you were just gassed,
you didn't do proper cardiac.
Yeah.
Number of times.
And then after that you're like,
fuck that.
I'm going to get on with your car.
Who was probably on point,
next fight.
Yeah,
for sure.
That next fight.
It's just,
uh,
you know,
there's so many,
there's so many aspects of your,
just your daily life,
they'll fuck up your cardio or fuck up
your training camp where it's like you,
he was saying like,
we're,
if Cornell would have done something
slightly different and it was like maybe
his girlfriend was pissed
off at him and you know,
you don't know what,
what else happened in his life.
It's just that just be crazy.
And then you're like,
well,
did I fuck this up because I didn't
train properly or because my fucking car
broke down and they couldn't,
you know,
whatever else happened in her life.
So interesting.
I like keeping peace in your life
with anything you're trying to do.
If he can keep peace
in your personal life,
the home life,
everything man to hit for each,
I can't tell are you get you get sick or
you broke your fucking toe and now you
can't run for that last bit.
There's a lot of guys
who were seeing me so,
or your shoulder joint was fucked up.
Now I can't do my sperm sprints.
And like all the shit that goes along
behind the scenes with fighters is it's
what,
uh,
how many guys do,
especially in entertainment,
being comedians who were out chasing
tail all the time and they're distracted.
Yeah.
That'll do it.
That'll do look at athletes too.
I know,
I know athletes who do the
same thing gets in your way.
Yeah.
It gets in your way,
the trip over your own Dick and it all,
people also use it as an excuse.
You know,
they don't do everything they could do.
So they always have that thing in the
back of their head that there's room for
improvement and uh,
yeah,
next time,
next time I'll get it together.
But you know,
most of the time that
next time never comes.
Your brain will give you these
sort of escape routes and that,
that's one of the ones that unfortunately,
it's,
it seems so counterintuitive,
but it happened.
So a lot of people,
I've never seen more of it
till I came to La Carnero one
last,
that last round.
Lucy looked like it for what we're seeing,
because Kenny Robinson
was coming on strong,
but to take down,
obviously virtually
didn't mission attempts.
Yeah.
Obviously we didn't score it.
The 30 I thought saw
I would give to Camaro.
One of the last round was
what was interesting to me.
It was because Kenny kept charging after
him and this is where it reversed him.
Does this on the last round?
No.
Beautiful.
Right hand
boom with a left hook.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's hard.
You know,
we're talking shit while we're
watching these things get barely stuck.
Really close.
Cozy.
I was think about Carl's
junior to be honest.
That fucking ad got me Carl's
Jr for some junk food right now.
Yeah.
I had a little junk food.
Now I'm fucking cheated a little bit.
I chill.
Chill a little bit.
It would be understanding.
Do you went off?
I went off like a rocket.
I went off like fucking Denzel
Washington flight where he,
you remember when he got into that movie?
He didn't see it.
He,
he's an alcoholic and they,
they'd give him a mini fridge
with just tons of stuff.
Just trying to recap and
just goes fucking nuts.
That was me.
Mm.
Yeah.
And now I'm back on it.
Now I hope,
but what year she'll fucking
took me back to the dark places.
The problem is if you get off Ketosis,
you got to do something to get
back on it again on Sunday.
Get the supplements.
You take the ketones.
Yeah.
He tells us you're doing
like the low carb thing or,
yeah.
Yeah.
I've been on it for grip now.
It done.
I'm gonna feel great.
Rather.
Yeah.
I'm also not fat anymore,
so it's a plus,
but I was happy with that.
Yeah.
It's a super plus.
Rick Glenn Power,
Evan Dunham,
Evan Dunham.
That motherfucker been fighting
a long time.
Matt still around,
still around and phenomenal
Jitsu and just says,
I want to bang.
Yeah.
He's got good striking too though.
He's tracking his just is phenomenal.
Yeah,
real good.
Yeah.
It's going to be an interesting for what
is this Batman nonsense or showing us
in this
commercial Radio National Batman Day.
Is it really?
Yeah.
My kids were all about it today.
Nashville,
Batman,
dude.
It's National Batman Day that it's like,
fuck,
I didn't know.
Hmm.
Batman.
The telltale.
Yeah.
Oh,
so they made it.
They made a DVD not to a
video game for x bucks.
Oh,
it's a video game.
I played the fuck of that.
If I didn't have a kid that we just
bought a Batman toy from the day,
worships back.
His boys love it is National Batman Day.
I didn't know.
Like Cheryl told me this morning.
Wow,
so what do you get around
it?
They're not going to know shit
up and then send me a text.
Where's your Batman?
I want to rock the Batman.
I got the old school Adam West t.
It's fucking dope.
Yeah,
I got it from junk food.
Did you ever read the story
of a Adam West and Wonderboy,
whatever his name is,
boy wonder.
Just fucking everything
that moves back down.
Let's have,
Yay.
Yeah,
he wrote,
he wrote a book about it.
The dude who played Robin wrote a book
about how much pussy they were getting.
Oh my God.
I went off.
I mean,
they were a big daily stories.
They never talk it.
Usually they don't talk about that.
You guys always keep that shit secret.
Are you telling me Robin was getting,
plus you have a hard time believing that
Robin was watching Batman fucker gets
pussy.
Come on.
Yes.
If you're on TV around,
dude,
it's a wrap.
He probably got so much pussy.
He's still catching his breath.
Got a TV in another year or so.
He's like,
I'm not ready.
I'm just recovering.
Corey Feldman,
he made an appearance on some talk show
and with his band and they're all girls
and angel suits and he's a
nightmare a fucking night.
Oh my God.
I saw that today.
It was incredible.
It was amazing.
He said a minor league baseball game
doing the same shit and there was seven
people.
That's what we're looking at.
Right there was that band.
Holy Shit.
Worse.
It's Corey Feldman's angels.
How could it be worse?
Please show.
This is on tape.
They put them on here.
I think
the today show them put
people on the clown.
He got trolled dance
to start as performance
viral right up there.
No one's looking at it,
right?
No one will see it.
You can't play this.
Just give us a little some something.
Hey,
for sure.
Make loss boys remake and quit doing this.
Grab ass with these angels.
You think it's up to him?
It's not up to him,
but he could.
Well yeah,
it's probably not an easy breezy promo.
Look at this Michael Bisbing versus
Dan Henderson for the UFC middleweight
championship.
This is crazy and insane.
That's going to be a wild ass fucking
fighting and Manchester cause those Brits
are going to go bananas.
Never lost there.
And also you got to form in terms of just
the fucking who's who monsters fucking
waiting in the wings with joc.
Reg Brock cold in Melbourne.
How about Yoel Romero versus,
I'm like a one nine tournament.
What do you guys call a tournament?
But whoever wins that is
fucking a tournament when
you're next to Joe Schilling.
I get excited.
I'm like,
why the fuck tournament
real tournament against
the best guys in my mind.
Did you see uh,
Jason Wellness and Simon Marcus
here the night she didn't fight.
I did crazy.
Right?
Crazy.
It was weird.
How,
first of all,
not,
not weird that wellness knocked him
out cause he can knock anybody out.
But we're that Simon at
the end of that round,
when he was letting him punch him,
was that odd to you?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean Kinda,
I uh,
I think Simon,
I think Simon and his coach had like a
falling out recently and I think it might
have something to do with him losing.
Oh yeah.
That's always
been like that kind of weight
when you fight Simon is,
it's like a very like ego based,
like very,
oh,
ego based,
the right word.
He's like tough guy.
Right.
So even in that fight,
like when Jason would do well against him,
wetland shots,
you would see Simon like blah,
and then come back with
like this big like a thing.
And uh,
I think that's what it was,
was I'm gonna drop my hands,
let this guy hit me.
And it also looked like it was
slowing down and we're a little tired.
Yeah.
He's so jack for a fighter,
you know,
it's usually very kickboxer.
Yeah.
Misha Tate,
Amanda Nunez.
Oh No,
no,
not her.
Not Her shit.
Uh,
uh,
who fought died?
Joanne Calderwood.
That Brazilian,
that Yoke Brazilian.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Jessica on drudge.
Holby she's a beast.
She dropped down to one 15.
She's fighting at one 35.
She was too small because
she's only like five,
three or five to,
I think she might be five too.
She's very,
she might be she,
you know what?
Pull that up because she
might not even be five.
She might be like five feet tall.
A little beast though.
She's so jacked.
How her back is just Vandelay.
How did that happen with
Usada outside east son?
Listen,
it's natural.
How tall she,
Jamie controlled.
I don't know.
She's three.
She might be lying.
[inaudible] Day and age where anybody
that has muscle has to be deucing.
Yes,
it is a,
there are weird to me when I see
girls that are built like dudes,
dudes that are built are girls dudes,
chicks that are built like
dudes are not on the juice.
Then who the fuck is show
me the ones that are,
well damn they must be weighed but hold
on though because there's levels of
testosterone naturally and some people,
yeah,
but there are some girls that are just
naturally jacked and once you think most
girls that sign up for
finally you're going to be,
they tend to have more testosterone
ditch naturally I would assume.
Maybe taking fight or loads.
If you go down that road you're using
knocking when fucking Miss America and
like your page vantage from
having sex with fighters.
The hot loads coming in there.
Those,
you know there might be some geology POC
you're on to some crazy shit be coming
in wanting to be fighters.
Then I had to the gym all the
time hanging out exactly like,
oh,
I've been here for three
years and I think it's mad
money to,
they've shown about women is that
women when they are forced to be the
breadwinner,
when women like when they become single
or are they have to take care of their
kids,
they have to work.
Their testosterone ramps up.
It actually changes open.
They're forced into a
position where they have to,
you know,
earn their money out there.
In the competitive world,
they actually develop more testosterone.
Don't ask me where I ask me to
cite my sources because he's short.
And then a Keith,
cause she's short.
She's jacked and there's
no doubt about it.
She just,
yeah.
Liz Carmouche she's Jack too.
She has,
she has no days doing curls.
Zero.
She's a tank.
She just got,
she has a new foot too.
Yeah,
right.
Did they announced that?
Yeah,
they did.
I forget who.
Who is she fighting?
I forget.
Yeah,
I don't care.
Hey,
I don't give a fuck.
how about Bahari verse a fucking Rico.
Rico Verhoeven.
Yeah,
we gotta relax,
man.
Butter.
Hari always be a fan.
But I think timing wise,
I think that a Rico's
going to beat him probably.
I liked it.
They gave,
bought her a long time to train.
Yeah.
I mean we're,
we're here in September and he's
been training hard since August.
Yeah.
Is it put all these videos on
Instagram marking the daisy jacked.
So what?
Of course he's jacked.
You mean?
They're like,
they got,
he's got some tamber October,
November and December.
Ricoh or who've is fucking huge guy.
Like a person.
You're just like,
fuck you see him before.
They'll fucking huge the other night
have that silver guy got Anderson brand.
Yeah.
He beat the fuck out.
That guy is not that big though.
I mean that's big.
Like shockingly huge.
Like fucking no,
no.
Ricoh little just toyed.
Rico's huge.
We also had sick cardio.
Yeah,
he's a sick athlete.
He's a great athlete.
He was a part of a first team.
All county sparring for
his really his fights.
Yeah.
Genius.
He did that a couple of years ago.
That is super genius.
SMART,
powerful.
Bruce buffer in every show.
That motherfucker travels
that motherfucker.
They go,
hey,
you sure you don't want to break?
Nah,
I'll go to every show.
Yeah,
he does every fucking show.
He's now,
he's doing this podcast.
I cut his punk ass.
Yeah.
I'm gonna fuck your blew his knee out too.
Yeah,
he caves Niantic Karaoke.
Missed three days.
Fucking came back in a white Tuxedo.
I talked to him about that and
it told him to get the surgery.
He's like,
Joe,
and think I'm not going
to get the surgery.
I go,
why?
He goes,
well,
I don't want to take the time off work.
I'm like,
are you fucking out of your mind?
I go,
get your knee fixed.
He's gangster man.
Then that world,
man,
you gotta hustle that world.
Stay on the quarterback.
Then Nfl,
Tom Brady,
you slip up.
There's been someone behind you.
Give me get on that mic and we'd come
up with who set up this guy behind verse
Buffett behind Bruce Buffers
his to scream.
Fuck it,
I'm adopted brother.
They don't know about if some dude,
if some dude comes in and tries to do
Bruce Buffer while Bruce buffer is gone,
he will be booed out of the fucking arena.
So he's going to surprise.
He's going to have to do his own shit.
I think you'd be surprised.
Cause range.
Then there's Bruce buffer
that was Michael Bumper.
So uh,
let's get ready to run ball right
and he doesn't do this time.
Then you get some new dude in
there who just fucking remix is it?
Yeah,
but that's not going to happen because
we would know who that got some black
dude.
He would already be comes in.
It's the bison.
It's a black dude for sure.
He boxing is the question mark
in the Midwest disagrees buffer.
Nobody.
Oh,
I'm not saying they are.
They're going to do their
own shit and flip the script.
Uh,
that's what Bruce is
worried about right now.
You're fucking with him
taking a day off now.
Crazy.
If some young kids not
just thinking about it.
These guys are going off here.
We're talking shit and I haven't done,
I'm just letting a beautiful combination.
It's hard not to root friend Evan Dunham.
He's been doing it for so long.
He has,
man.
It's a tough fucking game.
Ooh,
beautiful shot.
You're very good timing.
Okay.
I don't know anything about his opponent.
Is he still training out of a Vegas
usable if he's like extreme couture flow a
long time,
right?
It was with Ray.
I don't know.
I don't know where he's at now.
He's got a training goal now.
Did Ray stop training guys once he
signed up to the world series of fighting
thing?
Now he was there the other
day with Brad to Brad to vars.
Who's up in one of his students forever.
Wow.
Brad look real good man.
Real Sharp,
sharp winning streak and
then fell off a little bit,
but he's back now.
Right?
Well he find Yoel Romero son.
That'll do it.
Yeah.
To fuck your whole schedule up.
That'll make you better.
Fuck your life up.
Like there's some people
that can just move different.
We're built their front
and you're a lot older,
sir.
He's freak
Weidman and then [inaudible]
neck tie right there to go home.
You see how he freed his leg?
That's what it was all about right there.
Yeah.
Getting that leg free
and he pulled it off.
That was one of the first deep,
deep shit that was on a first
Japanese neckties ever in the UFC.
It was perfect.
That's what I meant by tournament Joe.
You know what I'm saying?
Like real tournament,
you know what I'm saying?
I told Joe Joe squared,
Yeah,
I totally real tournament.
But in my mind I was like,
we got our shelves with Metal Weight
turn him well Jack Array versus Rockhold
too is very interesting.
Actually.
Chris looks at me getting
all that model pussy.
He might be exhausted their Egan,
that Demi Lovato,
New York model.
That shit will fuck your life up son,
you know,
or take your take your next level.
I just am shocked that uh,
that he's not fighting Weidman again.
I felt like that would
be the fight to make.
Like the fight to make would be Weidman
versus Rockhold to not jocker rave what
you do with joc.
Romiro there
one more time.
We had a little problem with the dry,
let's see what happens.
Let's run this shit back.
He'd both gotta be clean.
So likewise members room.
So Weidman the,
I see,
I was under the impression that Shakuri
won that fight for some strange reason,
but I guess who wide,
I guess y'all were marijuana decision.
But then it turned out that he tested
positive for some peptide or something
like that.
And then they found the
supplement that he said he took.
They tested it.
It was positive.
So he gets a shorter break.
Check this out man there.
Plenty of time left.
And he's on his back.
We still have a finisher.
We still don't have any info on John.
Right?
So this is a spot where Kenny Robertson
caught that knee bar is right here.
He very similar.
Yes,
right here.
And you do it with the head as well,
right?
So the guy can't lean back
to be honest with you.
Oh you got the church should
be talking about digit two.
There you go.
Boom.
Oh Man.
Oh he is.
Oh it's over.
So go ahead and just touch it.
Touch it.
Going to gut it out.
All these cards,
Tyler
tion it's all time.
Go to sleep.
Sweet prints.
Oh,
amazing.
Amazing,
brilliant defense.
Do you go for it again?
58 seconds ago.
100% go for it.
He might go for an arm bar right here.
Yeah,
I haven't done them looking good.
It's been fighting for ever.
So this is a position he's
looking for an arm bar.
Look at that.
He's ready.
Yeah.
Look at this.
Shifted the hips
right back to this.
Wow.
Yeah.
He's attacking 30 seconds.
That much time left.
It's so rare that you see someone hit
that arm bar from the back when they're
going for the choke or even can take him
to the truck and hit him with the calf
slicer or a twister.
It's right.
I'm just going to try.
I
lost it.
Oh,
she didn't get the hips up in time.
She had a pillow out of Greece
going on in a Gracie style.
Oh,
one more time.
Flatten them out.
Poundage.
Go for poundage.
Oh,
we got half guard.
How about fuck.
Oh
God,
Dude.
How about steep based on over Overeem,
dude.
Overeating this whole time.
Like how fucking hard did he
hit him with those three shots?
Shots took him perfect,
perfect place.
I was stalking them earlier and he'd get
fucking hitting the guy in the head and
you guys talking about the triangle.
I'm like,
fucking [inaudible] shots had
been fucking but also Overeem's.
Not that you know,
his,
his mother board message board
has been hit a bunch of times.
Yeah,
well that's why after the fight I said,
I don't want to do interviews with
fighters after they got knocked out again.
I appreciate it all.
Appreciate that.
When he said that,
when he said that,
I don't fucking talk.
When he said the guy tapped,
I was like,
fuck.
Imagine if he tapped like,
are we going to see a
task like I had no idea.
You don't.
You don't know if you miss something
during the actual calling of a fight
because it's happening live and it's
so chaotic and it's right after Alister
dropped him,
then he went for the guillotine.
Then also they're on their feet again.
It happened so fast when he said it.
He was so adamant.
Yeah,
that's good.
I know.
What about the truck in the back though,
Joe?
Aren't they going Joe,
he didn't tap.
Do you really want to show them?
They don't know.
They don't know the fight live.
They watched the fight live.
Find a way.
Find out it's entertaining.
It was.
It's totally possible that if he did
tap that someone saw it in the truck,
they would have said it,
but they didn't say it.
But they're like,
we're going to,
we'll play it for you.
And I said,
okay,
we're going to,
we're going to play it.
And so they had a cute up,
they played it and then
he was still insistent.
I'm like,
okay,
well maybe it's the other hand,
but I was thinking,
man,
this is not look good,
but it has to be solved.
It has to be resolved.
You know when the guy says the guy tapped
him and handled to show champion part
of the game,
if you check it,
you have to show it.
Yeah,
they have to show him those.
But I wish we didn't interview him at all.
I wish,
you know,
I think you guys did have a chance to,
he was completely unconscious and it
took them a while to get back to his feet
and to have a conversation
with him about the strategy,
about where it went wrong.
And it's crazy.
It doesn't make any sense that
one more time,
but he doesn't have the leg
it all right there at dark.
This is a serious shit and got a guy
get loses and gets submitted it or
whatever.
But even in other sports or this sucks.
I wish I would have one.
Yeah,
he even in other sports like
the NFL for God's concussion,
your,
he's not doing interviews,
man.
He's not right in the head.
The guy breaks his leg,
ours a need.
They're not interviewing him because what
the fuck's again is you don't kind of
fucking frame a mind
that guys in dark nuts.
So you're 100% right Joe.
I love that.
Well,
you know,
it's something I had suggested a long
time ago back when we interviewed Mirko
Cro cop after Gonzaga knocked him out.
I was looking in his eyes that night.
You guys interviewed,
interviewed no more right after the fight.
And I was like,
we can't do that anymore.
And I said it to him and
we just kept dealing it.
What if it's good for ratings?
Like they do it.
They get knocked out.
Guaranteed interview.
You want to be good though.
I'm not doing anything.
They'll even show him
on the ground anymore.
They pan away on the camera.
They tell you a yes or no
Joe or they don't care.
I'm not doing anymore.
I'm not doing it.
When you guys getting shut the fuck,
you're going to find out if
guys get knocked the fuck out.
So if someone really
wants to talk to them,
they're going to have to talk to him.
I'm not,
I'm not talking to above was
going to jump in that bitch.
How do you fail?
Take it from here.
It's time for me to interview you,
Joe.
I'll take it from here.
Thank you sir.
I know you hate this part.
I got a raise.
I'm doing it out of respect for the game.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't think we need
to and I don't think,
I think the UFC agrees there.
It's just,
it's better for the sport.
What made Allister look bad?
And I think if you gave him a few
hours or even a day to talk about it,
he probably would realize
that that never happened.
And it was just,
his brain was scrambled.
Well,
even steepen when you're talking to me,
he's like,
hey,
hit me with a kick.
No Sir,
that was a boy.
He said the guy kicks hard.
Yeah,
he did get kicked hard
and the body and he did.
And uh,
I mean he could have been mentioning that,
but he probably didn't realize
what knocked him down was,
can cuss too.
Most likely.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
sure.
The way he got dropped,
flatland drop and he got staggered
more than once a hundred stagger twice,
at least twice in that first round.
So much pressure on seaweed.
Hometown.
I was so happy for him,
man.
You ain't heard roars like the
Cleveland crowd for Steve Bay.
It's like Dublin for Connor.
It's crazy.
They,
Cleveland is maybe or Cleveland,
but,
but they love him man.
And Cleveland is a bad ass town.
Man heard that it was
experiencing like this resurgence.
It's a fun town.
Those people were fun,
joy,
browns fan.
So it's terrible.
You know,
I'm not really into
football that much anymore,
but uh,
I did watch last week's Brown's game.
I'm so proud on Dvr.
I've Wah,
I didn't even watch their defense.
I just fast forward to the offense and
they played like shit and I usually you
feel like garbage after spending three
hours watching football by feeling your
team scores one touchdown,
you're like,
I fucking wasted my whole day.
Sat through all these fucking commercials
for this bullshit ass performance.
You feel like shit.
But when you fast forward
through it all and they realize,
oh,
I wouldn't have wasted my time.
I went through the whole
game in 20 minutes.
I felt great.
They look like shit.
That's not how you watch it.
So that's so fucking wrong.
Three hours for me,
if I would've just sat
through this shit is,
it's beautiful.
You didn't want to do that back in the
day because there's too many spoilers.
Everybody's watching TV and
there's a spoiler is everywhere,
but now you're like,
everyone's like in their own
little compartment on the Internet.
I'm like,
I never know the god damn
scores so you can DVR at game.
That's what I'm going to do tomorrow.
I'm not going to spend a kill a Sunday
watching football and wasted my time with
my son.
I forced them to watch
it at six months old.
It's a lot to the two in
the morning on fast forward.
It's the greatest.
Well now we know that you don't,
you know,
they're gonna they might've
done or they're doing it.
Hello Smith tonight.
Yes sir.
It is.
And it's a good fucking fight.
If you know about the Smith family,
I thought for that brothers,
four brothers,
two of them are going
to be world champions.
All four pro boxers.
It's nuts,
man.
That's a tough fight for Canelo to that.
Smith is a fucking monster he do at home.
Really know anything about.
It's tough.
Tough dude.
After that Kell Brook fight,
I want to see Canelo versus triple G.
Dude.
How about uh,
[inaudible] verse fucking
Andre Ward in November.
We should do a fight campaign for that.
I'm in from not doing so
celebrating online for that.
She knew was Viking Penguin
for Turkish oil rustling.
We should,
we got to find out when the,
when the date is like
their world championships.
Dedicate that.
Oh Dude,
that shit is only on Youtube.
You have to go there live
and bring your phone.
If you want
Callan who'd come out of Catlins mouth
crushing probably as a Turkey stacks it,
he's probably done it before and shit,
we should,
they got to have world championships.
There's gotta be some Hixon
of Turkish oil wrestling.
It's like instead of
getting drunk and gambling,
this guy just blows guys.
He sucks to me.
Dicks and has to take and that's
why he starts losing too many dicks.
So he's talking about it in interviews.
How he cut the dick out.
He's like,
no more decks.
I haven't had any dick in training
camp and feel really good.
I did one big on Sunday.
That's a cheat day.
Cheat Day.
I'm sorry you can't wait til Sunday.
Just sucks Dick.
It's like when does Sunday
county's waiting on this fight?
I thought that was the third round.
What's,
how much am I paying attention?
This is,
I thought that was the third round
thought that was the end of the fight.
Evan don't,
I'm still going strong.
They raised their hands,
uh,
after that round,
like it was over and I thought,
damn,
that was quick.
We're not paying attention.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's one of the craziest thing about
kickboxing is that when you go to the
third round,
those tournaments,
if it's a draw,
they'd make you guys fight a fourth round.
What the fuck is that feeling like?
It,
it sucks.
I'm not going to lie.
It sucks because going into
that third round you're like,
fuck this is it all?
Fuck,
motherfucker had to do this.
And then you're like,
you go back into your coach and like,
I think it's going to be the
next you're out and you're like,
fuck no,
like that Simon fire.
I remember like thinking,
think I don't want to,
I don't fucking one,
two.
And then we had to go another round and
then ended up working out great for me,
but I was not happy about it.
You guys should,
if you guys both agree to
flip a coin at the end,
it's like,
do you want to fight?
Do you want to find,
okay,
let's just flip it.
I'm sure he felt the same way too.
He didn't want to go.
He didn't want to do it either.
Well,
he kept spit his mouthpiece out.
I think his nose was shattered at broken,
so he couldn't close his mouth
because he couldn't breathe
and shit and you're like,
fuck,
can't breathe.
And then his mouthpiece,
Kevin coming out.
Hey,
so which happens a lot actually when you
see guys in their noses like bleeding
like crazy.
It's usually when you'll
see the mouthpiece start
falling out because he just
can't breathe.
Brendon,
I've got a question for you real quick.
We'll hop on real quick.
Our boy Kellen,
he's doing shows in New York and there's
an explosion half a mile from him,
so show got canceled.
Why?
It's,
yeah,
he just texted me.
He's like,
Hey,
explode.
Hey brother.
I'm sure you saw the news.
My show got canceled because
there's an explosion in New York.
What's he talking about?
Terrorists.
Hillary.
False flags,
right?
Think of a deal,
quote,
quote unquote.
Now their body double
20 I'll let them talk.
29,
she died on the 11th.
Tony,
I'll talk like 25,
26 people who've been injured.
No deaths.
There's a second device.
They don't not to explosion
that call in a bomb.
You're not saying terrorism?
Nothing crazy like that right now.
Oh come on.
But the talent shows canceled the caddies.
Callen was that he said a half a block.
Half a block.
He says half black or half a mile in one.
So I don't know,
but he said it shows
cancel and it was nuts.
Alex.
Jenny's.
Okay.
Cause there's going to
be a false flag event.
Watch Hilary's on her,
uh,
on,
apparently,
uh,
she's not looking to Gut Hillary.
She's super sick.
That's what people are saying.
Well like a September 11th,
she left the event early
and like passed out,
like collapsed and fainted.
Cops got like a fucking shit
bag in her and Manhattan.
Alex Jones had some position on and he
said he shot at showing signs of some
kind of brain tumor.
But Alex Jones is so far like he used to
come across like he had like good ship
and he's just kinda crazy.
And now he's like so far the other way
that I just can't take him seriously.
Like even if this shit is true,
like he just,
he's like,
oh,
the globalists,
the elite.
I'm not giving you my God mother.
Oh,
you just get
so far as the explosion.
Was it terrorism?
But it was done intentionally.
So that means someone
from here would do it,
but isn't terrorism,
terrorism?
Maybe someone just wanted to
get rid of their building,
got a shitty building.
He was calling you.
I ain't got a calendar with
all this Hillary shit going on.
They're panicking.
They don't know if they're gonna stick
Bernie Sanders in or they going to put
Biden in.
How can they do this?
Spend the election,
keep Obama and longer.
They're about to make a
big ass decision right now.
Hillary apparently is.
You're so excited.
I'm just happy.
[inaudible] said that
explosion next door is a cold.
I don't know.
Shit.
That's just what I hear it.
I who knows the Collins like
this can all be a trick.
Well,
I mean,
whenever you're dealing with someone
like a Hillary Clinton and you know,
she's super sick and you know,
you leading up to the election
and she just doesn't look healthy.
She's fainting and stuff.
Now she's old band.
She's old and she's a poor health and
she had a serious concussion a few years
back,
cushion,
real batch.
She fainted,
fell down and hit her head.
Have you seen,
apparently had a brain
aneurysm and you know,
it was bleeding internally.
That's how,
uh,
I'm not saying had anything to do with,
like Parkinson's or,
or these,
these fainting spells that she has.
Usually when you have this disease
with fire or whatever it is,
they usually die from the falls.
They usually die and they just cracked
her head on the subject and that's what
they die from.
And uh,
Alex Jones had,
you know,
he's saying according to
his of physicians that,
that,
and he's saying that he's got a
connection in the secret services size.
So she fucking scrap.
We're watching the crazy,
we're just talking shit about Hillary
Clinton the first of the fuck killer of
the world here.
That's what we're talking about.
We're not talking about just some,
oh,
he's locked up,
son.
Look at,
oh,
he's a,
he's on Zombie mode.
Oh,
Friday kids Zombie mode.
armbar and,
and then it's over.
Oh,
sick.
Oh Bell.
It's crazy.
God bless you in that arm bar.
How nice was Verdun was flying.
Fucking psychic.
Fucking loved it and kept
doing the fucking car.
Real clicks.
Guys.
We can't talk over each other.
It's horrible to listen to.
So let's regulate them to tell them
we got to definitely don't do that.
But yeah,
it was crazy.
It's case for crazy kick.
He's done it before,
but he did it when you
fought over a millwright.
People forget it.
Atlanta.
He did it before.
Yeah.
Really?
Wow.
That's interesting
little fact for you guys.
See each other before jumping
fucking sidekick characters.
Nuts.
He jump kicked fucking over him in pride
and straight out as s the Gif is so
good.
It's like,
it's just so fuck dude.
It fucking wobbled transplant.
Oh Shit.
The jaw.
It was a lot of wheel kicks,
man.
I like him a lot about,
we're doomed.
Said,
check this out,
flying fucking psychic.
Own your coach.
This is Sparta front kick.
Get Your Bullshit Jim out here.
Yeah.
That was real weird.
After the fight,
Edmund was screaming at them.
I'm like,
what do you think is going to happen here?
I think watching it,
I thought that he thought
that when he was fucking,
I think admin at some point thought that
Travis actually won that fight and then
he got robbed in the decision
which they were doing.
That's what I was,
no,
I think,
I think there's a lot of pressure on it,
so I'm doing this shit and was like,
oh shit.
I think there's a lot of pressure on
ed mean because you know it's like,
fuck man.
He gotta win a fight.
Traffic moved his whole camp there.
He's looked like pure Kaka.
There's a lot riding on this fight.
He just lost the cane,
so if you hear him in the corner,
there's desperation.
He's losing his voice and
then when that shit happens,
when your fighter fights like that,
I think he was just so furious
and he's an emotional guy,
but you're talking to the number when
heavyweight in the world and he's going to
twist your fucking face off when
you talked to him like that.
He's Brazilian and then in Brazil they'll
just fucking smack you for no reason
was a nice guy too,
for dooms a fucking grand human being.
One of the nice guys in the world.
You're lucky that was an over
him or someone like that.
Yeah,
it was all very weird.
It was very weird because I
didn't see it until afterwards.
I was climbing into the cage to do the
post fight interviews when he kicked him,
so I didn't see him kick him,
but all of a sudden Edmund went flying
a bunch of people in there and Hofeld
Cordura was trying to kick
Edmonds ass hot fucker.
Daryl was fucking fear and Edmond was
screaming at Hockfield Cordero and Hofeld
Codero was ready to throw.
I mean,
they cut all that off.
I was really considering
what he should or shouldn't.
Don't standing right back.
He's a bad mother fucker and Hofeld
Cordell was right in front of them
considering what he
should or shouldn't do.
And they were trying to
move Edmund away from him.
But he had said some nasty shit.
I don't know.
I don't know who said what or what,
but there was a lot of like extremities
when you see Dana didn't see any of that
came in and was like,
God,
come on,
we got cm punk before this.
No,
you got this bull shit.
You got a Brazilian and an Armenian
Brazilians that are mainly and have one
thing in common.
They don't take any shit on the street.
You get you say anything
to Armenian on the street.
We got fucked.
The Armenian Armenian.
Armenian.
Yeah,
but say the [inaudible] whatever.
Italian Albanian students that don't
say shit and throw our money in Armani's
Oh,
suit.
But the differences,
one of them is ranked number one in the
world and rip your fucking Dick off.
And the other guys just to get the
races are down to fight at anytime.
That's what I'm saying.
But one can fight better than the other.
That's where you got it all.
Now that's up.
Never heard of current European,
sir.
Are you being serious?
He was at one point.
I mean,
he's a fuckwit.
Edmund was a legit kickbox you're
backing in there compared to,
I mean,
not pretty sure he's a,
he's a piece of shit competitor for doom.
Doom so big too.
He's such a giant and he's top,
top three.
Best heavyweights of all time.
He just happens to be one of
the greatest guys in the world.
You know what I'm saying?
He's a really good dude.
Yeah.
So we showed him that he should
have kept his mouth shut.
Which one?
Edmond.
Who knows what was said.
So you can't say that and let's see.
You know what was said?
I know what you shouldn't do is approach
a fighter and try and fight him as a
coach.
We know that I don't give
a fuck what he said to you.
Yeah,
super controversial move.
I think that he just was
watching and they use pissed off.
This guy lost and then fucking
Verdomme starts doing this shit.
And he was like,
hey mother fucker don't do that shit.
And then Verdun was like,
who you talking to you?
Well what happened?
He's like,
don't fucking talk.
I said,
the reason why front kick and he goes,
cause I could tell in his eyes he
was going to throw a punch at me.
He said,
he goes,
I could have done something a lot worse.
He's right.
Did we don't flip off the audience.
They were weren't.
They weren't booing the fact that he won,
they were booing that the
fight was lack luster.
Correct.
But it was,
it was,
he wasn't blowing that like off.
Fuck you.
It was like,
Oh crap was right at the
top for doom was like,
we just fought her fucking ass off.
We're doing some shit.
They're there in the
fucking kids throwing down.
So no matter how it goes down,
the audience should never hold on.
You got to take this into consideration.
The audience is there.
It's in Cleveland,
steep,
a beat for doom for the belt.
They all know that they're
there for Steve Bay.
They know that for doom was the
guy Steve a beat for the belts.
So they're against VRE.
Do them anyway cause he's like the,
he's like the invading team.
I get it.
You're right.
It was a was,
it wasn't a good fight,
but I was amazed that Travis was able to
recover when Fabrizio got his back that
I was,
I was like,
wow,
I dude,
dude's got heart.
He's got some,
he's got some very good defense to cause.
Fabrizio had him,
dad had him hurt and then had them
down and then took his back and I was,
I was shocked that he didn't finish them.
I'm like,
that's pretty impressive.
Especially considering the
Travis had a broken finger.
His fingers fucked up.
You see the pictures of it?
I did too.
The pictures.
What's more impressive though is for
doom fighting and thrown a spinning or
kicks and the fucking flying
kick with a broken foot.
You know,
he went into the fight with broken foot.
Which foot?
I'm not sure.
That is impressive though.
That was impressive because
how impressive is that?
Wonder if it was the broken
when he kicked him with,
I'm sure ridiculous gangsters that,
well I thought that it was like a mental
warfare thing that I thought was kind
of awesome was that if,
I don't know the situation,
but saver doom wasn't in the best shape
and needed it to be a slower paced fight
and you come out and you do that flying
fucking push cake with a fractured site
and then all of a sudden you're doing
fucking cartwheel kicks cause you don't
give a fuck if he gets on top
of you and you're underground.
Wow.
And then next thing you know is a slow
paced fight and you get to win on,
you know I,
it was,
it was cool that that fights topman
cause both guys were in the show much
pressure because if we're doing loses
he goes to the back of the line.
He's older and this is this
fucking second time in the UFC.
Trash Brown.
He's one out of his last five.
He admin all this pressure.
So there's,
so there's just high tension man,
very high tension.
There was a lot going
on for of us for them.
Now he's like 49
yeah.
Yeah,
he's 39 you know,
it's interesting because the als to
fight like the way ouster was avoiding
exchanges and getting out of the way.
It's so like you're watching a
totally different fighter now.
It's so interesting.
Like you remember his fight with Todd
Duffy when he was the destroyer and he's
just
pants.
Yeah,
I know.
Exactly.
And then with Brock,
same thing pre Usada.
I mean that,
that Alister had such a different style.
Now he's moving around a lot.
He's got his hands out,
he's running away from exchanges and
picking his spots and trying to fight at a
really reserved pace.
He's trying to like preserve
his energy and pace himself.
But,
but what technique,
and I mean maybe you
would know better job.
What technique did they ever teach in
any martial art where you run like that?
I don't know.
I was called get the fuck
away from steep bank.
Right.
A lot of talk about it after Connor did
the tonight and other negative positive,
whatever.
We're talking about fatigue
and stuff like that.
And then I looked exactly like that,
but,
but Conor did it later in the
rounds when he doing the first run.
When you're not tired,
that's just that mean that's
your straight technique son.
Well,
I think if we do it on a football
field by Joe wants to have those
opportunities,
people are gonna be like,
Hey man,
this is too close to fucking
run away from the threat shop.
Metamorris running and
get their shit together.
[inaudible] field.
I'm out time to run or get
down some duties to down.
Remember when Max Holloway and Ricardo
Lamas to each other and pointed at the
ground,
so let's do this.
And they just swung through the
last 10 seconds of the fight.
Just one.
There's going to be guys that do that
too and there's going to be guided that
Alister it,
God bless them,
but I've never seen him.
Have you ever seen Allister like that?
Ever?
Not asked her.
Never seen it.
But you also have a straight left.
It drove to all of this beautiful though.
It was amazing and it
was off of that runaway.
The other thing that I
was thinking is like,
and even in nature when Nate and Connor,
when it happened,
when you do that,
like runaway thing,
you're getting a reset.
And then like for example with a Nate,
Nate's began kicking the leg a lot.
You're walking around
the the fucking ring,
he runs away,
you're walking to him walking to him.
He set now and he's waiting for you.
As soon as you come into distance,
like I gets like the jump on,
you know what I mean?
Which is a,
it's weird.
It's a thing.
Well it's a thing.
Well you don't have to move forward.
You don't have to advance right for him.
That'd be kind of interesting
if you just stood there.
I was,
it never went away.
I've never seen one
over him stealing ever.
Well you know what man?
He got tagged a couple of times and I
think he also realizes that steep bay is a
fucking dangerous guy.
And at this stage of his life,
he's not that good at taking a shot.
You know?
He's just not.
And then what?
What scenario would have been better
for him to do in that moment than to do
that?
That was the fucking right thing to do.
I think self defense right there,
you're in a bad position.
You're like,
oh fuck,
I got to get back to where I'm set.
I'm going to recitals.
Then why don't more guys run?
Well,
maybe that's the best forms.
A five round fight for heavyweight.
You're going to,
I don't think it's the best.
I mean,
but if that's he had at that
moment,
you know,
I mean,
it's not the best.
Like there's guys that fight
like maybe not in that division,
but there's guys that felt,
okay,
here's a perfect example.
Kane came,
we never do that.
Never seen it.
That you'd never gonna sit that over.
Yeah.
It's not even in their brain to run.
They don't have that pain's going to turn,
plant himself,
fire back,
try to take you down
and try to crack on you,
whatever it is,
you know,
and probably for doom is
not going to run like that.
Either.
Renew we're doing is going to look for
the clinch or he's going to try to take
you down as you move in like that.
I'm another heavyweight
that run like that.
Nobody,
nobody currently,
nope.
Nobody currently,
and there won't be a trend of it.
I would no guaranteed.
I think that was a high pressure situation
and he thought that was his best move
at the time.
But if you looked at what he
did with junior dos Santos,
he did a less extreme version of that.
He did a lot of moving away,
but he landed hard shots then
ultimately knocked junior outs.
Everybody forgave him for it.
Correct.
But it's that kind of movement moving
away from the conflict and ticking it's
best chance to win.
Two is if you look at Steve Bay's,
when he,
when he gets a guy against the cage,
he goes to work.
So maybe he was like,
you know what,
I'm just gonna Reset.
Go the center,
keep going.
Recentering cause we know how good steep
is with his game plan and back me up to
the cage.
I don't know anything about his grappling.
Tell me,
tell me who's Steve Bay
is a really good wrestler.
Recent College.
I heard he was a wrestler.
Let's pull it up.
Pull it all dress right.
Cleveland state.
So Division One.
Yeah.
And then so real good athlete and others.
Well,
baseball,
he's base plate.
Went wanted to play professional baseball.
His jujitsu's very good.
What Bell's not offensively.
Defensively.
Uh,
I don't think he's not high level train,
but his defense is amazing.
He's like Rashad Evans has defense.
Not really.
I no submission wins.
No,
no,
not a big disguise.
What about his striking specifically
blocks and golden gloves?
Champ from Cleveland.
Very good technique.
You see what he had going
house to her college wrestler,
Division One College Wrestler,
a college baseball player.
Do you see when he had a Alster against
the ropes or against the cage and just
hit crisp combinations?
Oh yeah.
Top,
top,
top.
This fight is a motherfucker
head like a pit bull.
You can take a shot.
This fights going to be fun.
I'm excited for this,
but yeah,
she'd be a good one.
You have the heavyweight divisions in a,
in an unusual position right now.
You know,
it's really interesting
to see what happens.
Really interesting to see.
Um,
how well Keynes recovered from surgery.
Obviously he looked like a
monster again against Travis.
That looks like the cane of old,
you know Cain steep based the flight.
It's the only fight.
Yeah,
that's what you guys think about
Tony Ferguson versus dos Anjos.
That's a mother fucking fight
and it's in Mexico City.
Kids dog.
Tony.
I'm going to be in big
bear for four weeks.
I instagrammed a picture
from big barriers.
He at Tito's hold joint.
No,
he's gonna run his own house
and Geo Chai compel out.
We're all going to go up there
and wrote a great fight man.
When Tito was in his prime,
he bought Oscar de la Hoya,
his training camp up there.
It's dope as fuck man.
I heard it's,
he had the cage
set up there and he would
do all his training.
He still owns it,
does he?
He was on our show and I think
you said he's still owns it.
Maybe Mosley has one too.
And he was out to uh,
to Canelo.
Canelo has a spot in San Diego.
We got to talking about how um,
being at an altitude
or being a big barrier,
it doesn't work as far as
l two wise because it was
still do it to get like away
from the world and get like focused on it.
What do you mean by it doesn't work?
Certainly there's arguments about um,
it's better to sleep low or to train low
and then see Pi and then people go up
there to big bear,
which if you're not there,
I guess the argument is free not there
for a long enough period of time.
They are actually getting less out of
your workouts because it's harder because
you can't breathe and
then it links it actually,
which is the whole concept behind it.
Yeah,
I do like the,
when you were asking what I do for cardio,
like I'll do a,
and I've been doing it for
fucking years and years now.
Probably since I really took off my
career was a high altitude training with
the,
I have like a machine that pumps
nitrogen so you're actually getting less.
It's simulates whatever altitude
that you want and what do you do?
Like a sprints on a
treadmill I'll do like a,
I'll as soon as I signed the papers,
if I have six weeks,
eight weeks,
however long it is for the fight,
like I just started sleeping and using
it when I sleep and then as I had my
cardio gets good and I'm starting to
feel confident in my cardio and I need to
start working it and testing it.
Then I'll start doing like
a tabata sprints with the
fucking the mask at 10,000
feet on the trek.
Kirsten has been doing it on like
a treadmill a lot or not tribal,
a rowing machine.
But then I live in do pad work.
I do bag work or to do all kinds
of shit with that fucking thing.
You're not just a device.
Are you talking about
that training mass thing?
Fuck that mass and that
that was going to say,
actually I'd say a hypoxic co is the
brand and it's this big machine and it
pumps nitrogen.
And so as the same you're taking the same
breasts but like volume wise of those
same breasts where I'm breathing oxygen
now it would be 80% oxygen at 20%
nitrogen,
which lowers the amount of
oxygen that you're breathing.
And what that does is it tricks your
attends this makes your body golf.
Fuck,
I'm not getting enough air out of edge.
Each breath I need to be more,
more uh,
whatever.
So you'll body will release e uh,
red blood cells from your bone marrow and
that's how you increase your red blood
cell or home.
Hmm.
That's like safe.
Which is,
which is what the,
it's like that's blood doping but it's
like on like a way lower scale Ganguly
yeah.
My coach notices it right away.
When I started using it like the a
year lytec acid buildup and like your,
your cardio will increase
every time you do it.
And you do.
How many of those a week peak training?
When I'm like peak it and
like it depends on every,
like I said,
every camp is different,
but like I'll try and I'll at least twice,
three times.
But you're seeing it.
I'm sleeping in at night.
Yeah.
It was one of those tests.
I had the big tent and by chick
didn't like it and the tent was like,
to say it was like too big because it
was like a room and the room it gets hot
and then it smells like you're
sleeping on the fucking tent.
I had one of my son,
I was like awesome.
Like soup.
Yeah.
No.
Well it's a big ass fucked
your whole night up.
It's a big ass tenant has like my fucking
dressers and like it's a fucking room
in the room.
So then I ended up getting a,
uh,
like a,
a pod.
No,
like I fucking made it.
I was,
it's actually really,
well,
I wonder if I have a picture oppressive.
I'm in the air that we got like
these plastic bins at home depot,
the biggest plastic bin and could find,
I cut like one wall off of it.
I'm like,
kidding thing in the back.
And then I got a,
uh,
a sheet like a tarp and I ain't
get so it's inside of the inside.
Like when I lay in,
there's like a fucking
plastic bin over my head.
Damn.
Hema Gaiman is out plastic tarp was lays
over the sheets or whatever and it was
pumping the how you sleep.
I love that word.
So it definitely works.
Definitely works
dude.
I'm gonna see if I find them on the phone.
Bless you man.
It can't be like paranoid of close
spaces when you're in a spot like that.
No.
You chick sleep with you two in there.
That's the only way that she would like
do it cause she didn't want the biggest
10 anymore.
Now I have like sometimes like she'll
get in there but like she didn't like it
and then it's really way too close.
That's hilarious.
She should do.
But that a,
it does really increase your,
um,
like your,
your car do it this way.
Have you been one of those Joe?
No.
I never slept one of the nice home one.
Yeah,
the soup thinks hilarious.
Would you own chamber?
Hyperbolic.
A hyperbolic.
A hyperbolic,
so it was less oxygen.
Like when I was talking to us and it
was one of those like pods and Barrick.
I watched all these things.
You see that one on the top left?
It's like just over his head.
Yeah.
It looks like that's what I,
that's what I
click one gentlemen is try
and take your rod hall down.
You write all props to
Joe making your own shit.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Slang those dogs,
hyperbaric chambers,
that's or hypo barrack or
hyperbaric different things.
Right.
One of them was his pumps.
Tons of oxygen.
Right to you and that's just supposed
to be really good for like knock out
recovery and stuff like that
and then what I have is to,
it decreases,
your honor.
You're basically suffocating
yourself all night long.
Which one were you saying?
Your body's like,
oh fuck,
you need to be more red blood
cells because you're dark,
which when Shan't Shanda pumps the,
all the pure oxygen.
That's the hyper is it?
Isn't it?
That's what I had.
I thought it was hyperbaric.
Hyperbaric.
Yeah,
hyper bag.
That's all I had,
but it was soft,
so I guess it wasn't working as well.
So then I went to a guy
in la that had a hard one.
It was like this thick glass.
Well,
I know why you're Ryan Faber
used that after the Aldo fight,
their repairs leg after he got leg kicked.
Yeah.
Which is a PR.
It was a brutal fight to
watch his leg swole up.
Derek Brunson with a
good knee to the body.
I don't see this fight last long.
Well,
Bronson was able to stop the bum rush,
which is big.
Oh,
you got a lot of time though.
See that spinning kick,
powerful Jamison shorts
when you're at home.
Just spinning.
Kick man.
It's his straight shots.
He's,
he's so efficient
with his movements.
When he's striking,
he's tough to take down,
man.
He was with us at rain.
He's a fucking freak athlete.
I think his distance is really hard
to read to this movement patterns.
And then the distance that
your highest strikes from is
Bronson banks at Danforth shelling.
Oh,
that is a wrap.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
dance it.
Dance it.
I'm not mad at that dance.
Wow.
Just can't get on track.
What do you think about that stuff?
That was,
uh,
you know,
me and what he needs to sell.
What do you think?
I think was way pretty much mature.
Let's see the replay.
It's herb dean again.
I mean,
herb dean is a bad motherfucker.
Dude.
If herb thought it was premature,
he might've been.
Herb thought it was time.
He might've been able to see something.
You know what you,
what kind of triggers a little bit is
Uriah went for a single leg on herb dean.
That's usually a bad sign he did after.
The fact he should have
did is after he stopped it,
he went for a single again.
Herb,
we're supposed to put up
a clock to sync this up.
Do you have a clock that syncs up Jamie?
Okay.
So far.
I was almost thinking about rewinding it.
That'll fuck up our clock,
right?
Brunton st title shot.
He got a relationship.
Same title shot.
You gotta relax.
Let's check this out here to see what God,
I've been there myself.
Good.
Left Hook.
Beautiful.
He's,
he's pounded them.
Boom,
boom.
Oh,
he's not really doing much there.
He get his lifted his arms up.
Now watch this.
This how you know he's fucked up.
Watch him shoot this
beautiful single leg on her.
Oh,
what a left.
Oh my goodness.
Oh,
he his head him.
No,
no,
no.
You've got to give a
guy a chance to recover.
Who wasn't even hitting him.
That's a little premature.
He was fucked up though.
I mean he definitely got tacked up.
We're getting dropped.
I just,
I don't agree with that.
He was trying to move
Herb's a little off tonight.
Can we all agree on that?
We're all friends.
We all love him.
No,
he's definitely,
I think this,
this was off.
Cut Him some slack.
This was off.
That's such a great job.
Yeah.
Herb's having an off night.
Everyone has an offline
in the office sometimes.
I don't know man.
I mean it's,
it's interesting because I would like
to see Brunson actually finish it.
Finish it.
I mean I think maybe if you gave him more
time he would have been able to finish
it conclusively and we wouldn't be
sitting here doing this and it would still
cause you don't want to take
anything away from that left hook.
That was beautiful that you know what?
That was a little premature.
I agree with that.
He,
this time,
I think it was premature and tears money,
they'll left.
The other ones didn't get
it cause you know what?
When he shot that single leg
to get up on her right away,
he was like,
Yo,
what the fuck?
He also grabbed him.
I was like,
Oh shit.
Come on man.
Why is your leg here?
Why do you have pants on?
What's going on here?
I mean he was turned up and
probably closing his eyes,
you know turtled up trying to avoid the
punches that were coming in his face.
But who knows?
It just seemed like they didn't land.
It's like he got hit
with that one big shot.
He goes,
but then the two
afterwards,
they were kind of deflect his head.
Was it?
He was,
he wasn't doing what a guy who was
conscious with do with his head or neck.
I feel like he was certainly conscious.
It's a matter of how compromised he was.
Yeah.
Well cause if you look at it,
the head's not moving at all.
You know what I'm saying?
Like he's,
it says not reacting to anything.
His arms are up stiff and it's not moving,
but it was enough to stop the two punches
that he was trying to throw at him
from hitting them all is,
is that him or is that bad?
Is it a shot?
Right.
We're on the fence about that.
I think you let it go.
I agree with you on this one.
I agree with you.
Here's where you give the herb dean.
The benefit of the doubt though said herb
was looking in his eyes while all the
shit was going down and he
might've not been there.
I agree.
He might've been off in the dark lands
or wrangle from different from the camera
is it actually looks
like he's getting hit.
Yeah,
horses are angle just as better.
Maybe.
You know,
I would say that herb has
the best view ever though.
Right?
Top of them ever.
It's interesting.
It's hard to,
hard to really predict.
Where are they tonight?
Hildago where the hell is that?
South Texas near the border of Mexico.
Cause I put Hashtag where the fuck is
Hilton and then Pique some guys like I'm
out.
I'm from their asshole.
If you're from Hildago closest
major city to rattle dog Max.
Whereas for as,
yeah,
I actually don't know.
I have no idea.
Don't quote me on that.
If you want to fly in,
you got to fly to Mexico and they
take you over on some sort of a shot.
Am I right?
Yeah.
No it isn't right on the border.
Public schools paying off son.
Wow,
that's,
that's really right on the border.
How many miles is it from
the border of Mexico?
Let's just do it in Mexico.
Hong Yossi.
Holy Shit.
Oh God.
It's right there at about wars.
They should've just brought an all Mexican
fighters and treat it like a Mexico
City card.
Doesn't have cartel is
there's the security sick,
fucking sick,
and then they all come out to
Mariachi bands and narco songs.
Yeah.
They're all at the Canelo fight.
But you,
it'd be,
that's right.
Yeah.
That's what they do in
the Dallas Stadium Son.
How about Liam Smith?
He's never fought outside the UK and like,
oh,
cool.
Here's Canelo in Dallas stadium sold out.
Get you somehow.
Was it the 50,000 people?
60 something.
60,000 can.
Nelson's can sell some fucking tickets.
What's interesting is
Gennady Golovkin can't.
I know.
It's weird like he does pay per views.
They don't do well.
They really don't know.
That's why he fought an HBO last week.
Yeah,
he's not,
he's,
he's not really a paper view fighter,
but man,
in my eyes,
there's no more exciting
fight or maybe ever,
he's blood and guts nasty.
He's up there.
He's got nasty boxing,
beautiful movement.
He gets on the mic,
goes big drama show.
I'm here to try big drama show.
All right,
man.
We need something else on crank.
Here it goes.
So he's down.
Boom,
boom.
See the limp left hand and you
see the limp lefthand though.
Not doing
much.
It's hard to see from there.
Let's see it from here.
We can all agree on this.
How's it beautiful?
Left Hook.
No,
those don't land,
man.
Here's my thing is that he loves,
he's probably still fucked up from
that shot while he's down there,
but none that you didn't stop him from
the shot and then those three things that
he threw all miss.
What?
What changed?
You know?
Yeah.
He's certainly controversial.
He was definitely fucked
up on the ground there,
but he wasn't getting more
fucked up when he stopped in.
It's too bad.
It's controversial because Bronson
landed that perfect letters.
The last shot would never want to
take anything away from that moment.
You know?
That's nothing on Bronson.
Right?
But it is.
If everybody could says
it's a bullshit stop.
It just makes you feel bad.
But people are going to clean.
They are.
You're going to have to give
your eye a half your paycheck.
Now,
I hate to be shitty about it,
but could they fucking please put a 145
pound weight class in instead of having
Cyborg starve herself every
time they let her fight?
He doesn't make any sense.
Well,
because at one 45,
she didn't kill a bitch at least.
So one 40,
she was dehydrated.
What poor soul is going in
there to fight this girl?
Could there be a scarier
fighter and Cyborg?
Uh,
the woman,
Lena landsburgs her name and she's a world
Muay Thai champion and she's actually
a,
she's actually very bad ass.
Fantastic.
Fly Down Brazil and
fight Cyborg in Brazil.
She's going to punch
you in the face so hard.
Now you want to talk
about Mike Tyson effect.
There you go.
Why don't you relax?
Who's Lena Landsberg.
She's a world moy.
Thai kickboxing.
She's very,
very good striker.
She got nasty elbows particularly good
in the clinch needs to the body over the
top.
Yeah.
And I bet she's great.
Anyone want to bet on that?
Yeah.
Bitch didn't even know what she was.
Fights like what happened you,
she arena Bahrain.
Serina bar.
I sure didn't [inaudible]
the same way class 35 years.
She's bad.
Yeah.
Cyborg is a monster.
She's terrifying.
She beats the shit out of checks,
but she lost two surely.
Gonna feed your lost two
jury in a barge in a fight.
We're bars.
Dominator.
There's land.
Lina Lansburgh.
She's good dude.
She's a good kickboxer.
She's got good striking good movement.
She's good man.
That's your shit,
right?
Yeah.
The Front Kick Jab while she throws a
round kick and then she comes from behind
it when you were recovering
with a right hand,
but she's got good
elbows in the clinch too.
The question is,
is she going to be strong enough
to keep cyborg off of her?
That's the real real question.
Is she going to keep her head
enough to use our movement?
Kunar technique.
She's fucking good dude.
She's a good striker.
Doesn't go past two rounds.
I don't think so.
Too Bad.
Brian counts on here to bet you in a
way where he would 12 fucking grant.
Those guys say if you let me
cross side rails going to hunt.
You got me fired up,
Joe.
I'm done.
Benton county basement Callen bet.
And then he lost the
second you look just go double or nothing.
They bet six grand.
He lost.
He's like Dell,
we're nothing.
So he loses again and now he's goes,
I haven't heard from him.
Yeah,
he's kept that bombing
because probably I'm safe.
Let's just forget about the money.
He said,
he said,
bomb.
It doesn't have to pay you.
I had your money.
We've got blown up.
It's fucking crazy.
It was going to shoot.
I need more time.
It's going to sound amazing.
Yeah.
You can't bet that those large sums,
unless you're going to pay up.
That's a lot of money that you're paying.
A friend was a pimp.
Did you guys see that?
Yeah,
that's George.
George.
What's the fuck's his name right?
George Hamilton.
They have a different Carol
Sanders every week now.
I liked the pimp one.
Rob Rickles one.
Now they should keep that one forever.
I would like to see our,
what was your two bets?
He bet on a owner ideas.
So he bet on Diaz and the first fight
and then he bet on Overeem in the steep
steep,
but he's the one that wanted him and I go,
dude,
I don't want just pay me.
My money is no,
no over him.
Steve Bay.
And he goes,
you get a pick first.
I'm like,
I'll take steep bay,
but you got to pay me go.
It's fine.
I'll take over him.
So when he lost,
you've guys have done podcasts since then?
What?
What kind of conversations
have you had about the money?
That he lost it.
He's like,
do I have to check my car?
Blah Blah.
And then we do the show and
then after you just dip south.
So you ask him point blank,
are you wanting your money?
Yeah.
And he's like,
I swear I'm going to pay,
but I run the,
I guess where I'm going to pay.
The thing is like,
yeah,
it's tough when it's a friend,
what are you going to do?
What am I going to fucking not
pay him for the tee shirts?
Yeah.
That's what I,
boom,
I could just not paying for merchandise
or are you just going to accept the fact
that everything with
him is sort of theater?
That's what I'm going to accept
that I would never take money from.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I mean,
if he gave me a check,
here's a lot of money,
man.
If you lost $12,000 and came to him with
$12,000 in a bag and just handed it to
him,
pushed it over to him,
he said,
are you sure?
And you're like,
yeah,
you won.
Do you think he'd give it back to you?
I do.
Really?
Just keep going.
No Brian better than me,
but I feel like you would.
I just keep going double or nothing
until he wins and then there you go.
That's what he was hoping.
But now I won't bet on that
cause it because the bits
that you can't make a bid,
it can go before he,
he's eventually going to win.
You'd be surprised how
be to pay you,
but just see how high
you well will know it.
No one cares if we,
if they know that,
that he's never going to pay them.
Why would care wipe the,
here's the thing,
you see how you can go.
I have to hold them accountable.
It Cowan is on a plane that gets
hit by an asteroid and he dies.
You go after his family.
Yeley tell us why you got my socks.
I'm gonna need that 12 gauge.
Let's document it on and he
goes flying 5,000 you're like,
let me just take this test I
me listen to 12 becomes 24 real
quick,
real quick.
24 becomes 48 real quick.
You don't have becomes 24 cause he
wanted to bet on your oil versus Weidman
cause I want Weidman.
No,
he wants to go more.
He wants to go.
Ya know he has to go.
We got it figured out.
Oh Man.
Come on man.
That's entertainment.
Bravo is 100% right.
Pretend like you really want the money.
Said that your your audience.
You can't pretend I really
want my fucking money.
This is show Business Brenton.
I don't bet like that with friends.
I'll pret a friend 100 bucks.
I don't mind paying a
friend a hundred bucks,
but like I don't want
anybody giving me $1,000.
It feels shit hurt.
I agree.
I don't want to like take away from his
kids horse riding lessons or some shit.
That just seems like that's a
weird thing with like rich dudes.
Like if you're like a Lorenzo Fertitta
or some sort of a super rich dude type
kit,
like if you're going to have a bet,
that shit has got to be preposterous.
Please take care heart rate
that just free to care.
Mark Cuban and Lorenzo Fertitta,
they get drunk together one night
and they decided let's get down.
You want to have a bet motherfucker.
They get crazy and they look
at it like a $50 million bet.
Right now they're getting
little private jets.
You know what I'm saying?
Different level.
Oh Man.
Got To have a rich before.
Holy Shit.
What's,
how's the Rondo Lorenzo Party
and these days I to same,
nothing chose spaceship and he's
just gonna just have a window.
We're only as dick hangs out.
Go.
If you had $1 trillion,
why don't you just go
everywhere in a helicopter?
You would just like,
I don't know man.
I fuck with traffic.
Can you imagine the stereo
system he has in his helicopter?
Holy Shit.
Changes shows guys.
Yeah,
I think there were already so super rich.
They're just,
you know,
more super rich and if I had a guest,
he's probably going to get into the
football game because he's a big fan of
football and kids coming to Vegas.
Kids play football.
They're talking about that.
They've already there.
There was a raider front office looking
at the facilities for practices already
and then
the Oakland Raiders will go there.
Interesting.
I guarantee that the Fertittas
we'll have some part in that.
They're great guys.
They're bro,
you don't have also hurt and I don't this,
it could be true.
I don't know.
This is from guys dealing
with them since the sale.
Everyone says Dana is so much better to
deal with on negotiations was from I.
There's I guess in sales he's just way
cooler to deal with now for whatever
reason.
Maybe,
you know,
who knows?
But they say just wait.
You know,
not that he wasn't
impossible to deal with.
I just,
just,
his demeanor is completely
different in a positive way.
Interesting.
Which was cool to hear.
Yeah.
I mean he was already,
Dan has been super rich for a long time,
but there's super rich and then there's
like how many hundreds of millions of
dollars did he make from their Cheddar?
He hasn't got all of it yet.
They have to,
it's like over years,
but still,
whatever.
There's,
there's like a level up from what I've
heard from people that are going through
negotiations right now that like,
dude,
heat.
That's crazy.
He's like,
he's way better deal with,
hmm.
Interesting.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
I'm very curious to see what these guys,
you know,
Aria manuals,
a super savvy entertainment dude,
you know,
his uh,
knowledge about the business is pretty
much unparalleled or at the very least at
the top of the heap it's him and then ca
he's got some crazy connections the way
it's going to be interesting to see
what they can pull off because you know,
the,
I don't know how long the
deal with Fox goes on,
but you know,
other two years I was having
a conversation with Dana
Way back before they were
uh,
doing this Fox deal.
They were talking about buying a network
at one point in time and it was like
right before the economy collapsed and
if they wound up buying that network,
who knows where the fucking
spoiled I think's going to happen.
I think once the Fox deal is up,
and I may have,
may not have heard this from some smart,
smart people involved in it,
you know how the NFL and NBA,
it's just not on Fox,
on CBS,
NBC,
they think Espn Fox,
like they're not going to just
be on one network with just Fox.
Have the lightweights in the West on NBC,
you're going to see like
ESPN promoting UFC fights,
big time.
Some fights.
You can see Fox doing it
similar how the NBA and NFL,
this does make sense.
They just did a NFL game this week,
broadcast that on Twitter
live on Thursday night.
Like it was on the actual app like
on the website or on your phone?
It was on Twitter.
I just whoa.
So he could watch the game on Twitter.
Trending was trending and then
next to a little live button or,
whoa.
That's intense.
Do you guys have those things?
Those are less scans that you put in your
bed and you clip your phone where you
could just watch your phone like shit.
None.
Cause generally if for the
longest time I'd have to hold it,
kind of set it,
you know,
if I want her to watch anything on,
on my pound now my wife got,
yeah,
we're awesome.
Clip where now I look forward to
getting in bed and just watch a Netflix.
Why don't you get an iPad?
Yeah,
let's just pause on the TV.
The [inaudible] person.
I do that too.
But it's nice to get in bed cause you
know if you take an iPhone here and you
hold it to your face like that,
that's like sitting in the
last row in a movie theater.
No it's not.
It's going to fuck your eyes is it is.
Yes it is.
Know your eyes don't move very much.
When you look into the last
row of a movie theater,
you looking at this big thing,
it's still a big thing.
You're moving your head around.
Lot of Shit's going on.
This thing is you got to like,
oh there's a little thing
right in front of me.
I got to pretend as big.
Think about it.
Think about it next time
when you're lying in bed,
turn off all the lights and then put
your phone like this close and it's,
it's like it's the exact same proportions
that of you're sitting in the last row
in a movie theater kind of,
Ooh,
look at this.
This guy's getting each other's
face right before the fight.
Well you know they have
those Vr goggle headsets.
It's actually a phone.
You slide a Samsung phone until like
this VR goggle and it becomes like a
virtual reality headset.
Samsung phones blowing up like crazy.
Are they note seven how well
that's going to destroy Samsung?
It's going to destroy them.
Who's going to hurt?
They blow up.
Oh,
are people dying?
Dude,
people,
they actually blow up.
I like they're blowing up.
Narda video taped his house is his house
caught on fire from a fucking Samsung
Samsung phones blowing up.
Literally.
Look at that.
That's not good.
Oh No,
they're done.
There was where a doc
right now with Samsung.
Oh he did?
He dropped radically.
No more microwaves,
nothing.
He,
there's one where a guy
was in his driveway.
He had his car,
a phone charging just
sitting on his console,
burst into flame,
came out,
his dog was barking,
is fucking cars on fire ablaze in
his driveway from his goddamn phone.
They videotaped the whole thing,
so he's like,
what the fuck is this?
Your kids have go through your phone.
I can look at videos and shit.
You let them watch cartoons and you're
feeling every now and that blew up on
them.
Call Man.
Well,
six year old boy did apparently get
burned from a afar a phone blown up and is
calling these phones.
Can you imagine how many people
got fucked up from him too?
They'd be called a million phone.
Holy Shit.
1 million phones.
I wonder how many accident can you
find out how many accidents Jamie,
is that possible?
Just said there was like 25 26 26
reports of burns and 55 reports.
The property damage including fires.
That's a lard for fucking phone.
I bet that zero for iPhone.
I've had zero I phones are blowing up.
Yeah.
Well this is the first time this has ever
happened with any major manufacturer.
I've never heard of anything like this.
Like that thing you were talking about,
hey look,
this car is back in the day
like the Pintos and shit.
We're killing people.
Right,
but that was from accidents.
They get rear ended and the
gas tank was in a bad position.
How about that thing you were talking
about Elon Musk and came up with a battery
that store solar energy.
Will they had those,
would that be oh,
you kind of sell the,
told him all this energy.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
You'd want to put that in the back shed
light on the other side of the backyard.
It's a good point.
Blows up like the Samsung phones,
right?
Yeah.
Bill.
Good point.
Because think about how small the phone
is and think of how big the battery bank
must be to power your
fucking j Lo Mansion.
Oh,
that's what the,
hey,
that's what that the energy companies,
you can just start false flagging like
houses go solar energy's blowing up
houses
and then they'll go like,
oh,
we're going to stay on the grid.
Fuck that son.
Shit.
Yeah.
Why do we go?
What are you thinking about this site?
We think about this fight.
Tremendous amount of shit
talking between these two.
Wayne's were fairly good.
It's a really good fight.
Man.
Johnson is,
uh,
it's,
it's very interesting because he's,
he's,
uh,
at times like looks real good striking.
But the question is,
does he have enough to hang with poor,
Yay.
And it,
does he choose to strike with him
or has he tried to take them down?
Like what is he going to do here?
It's going to be really interesting.
Pull a pretty much has the same
strategy always presses forward and,
and tries to strike.
Looks great at this weight class though.
Jamie just pulled up some shit with
our ready on Tesla for blowing up.
Right.
Put that,
put that back up Jamie.
There's said tests.
Look,
this Tesla's spontaneously catches fire
burns down during test drive in France.
What they should put that on all they
to put that on CNN all day for a week.
That's it.
And then that's it.
That it's so easy to get
rid of good technology.
Well they had a problem with
Tesla's early on were uh,
if underground debris or a ground debris,
like if they rolled over some,
some rocks or something like that and
it damaged the under carriage that I get
to have some issues.
So they fixed that issue
somehow or another,
they probably like poly urea coated the
bottom of the cars or something is they
put a titanium shield on the bottom there.
You got that?
No ma'am.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's so easy to get rid of Tesla.
This is an interesting fight here man.
Cause Michael Johnson at one point
in time was looking real good.
He was climbing that ladder.
[inaudible] Wind Street,
but the Nate Diaz fight
set them back quite a bit.
He got dismantled in that fight.
Those the best nights ever looked.
Good luck being that Nate.
Yeah.
Nate looked real good man.
And I was talking to Ludwig about it and
he was talking about how the way Nate
throws his one too.
He goes like most people go one to like
the left hand and then the right hand
comes behind it with Nate.
They're coming at you at the same time.
Yeah.
It's like,
ah.
They're like,
they're coming together.
Yeah.
He's like,
it's a totally different reason.
Oh,
hold on.
Yeah,
for sure.
Just goodness.
Oh my goodness.
Henri Hooft and Michael Johnson.
Michael Johnson.
Got It done.
He's doing the gimme my money.
He was doing the Johnny Man.
Oh,
Mike.
stand over here.
Oh Wow.
Well,
you know,
you just said fuck you bitch.
Wow.
It's a fight.
He said fuck him.
Fuck shit talking.
Wow.
There must have been some serious
shit talking before this to him.
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't do that.
Why lunch?
You guys find out you can't
do that at this point.
He can remember one tank,
Abbott fought,
uh,
no mark or you flub something now
more than it wasn't drama too.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't him.
It was a taekwondo guy.
I forget his name,
but he thought a taekwondo dude who
fought in the earlier UFC and tank fucked
him up and he fucked him up too long.
And the ref try to,
John Big John McCarthy try to stop it,
but he hit him like an extra shot.
And then the guy tried to fight
tank after that for fucking him up.
It was so weird.
Like he wanted to fuck him up
for fucking him up to do it.
They're trying to rally.
Johnson had just been like,
dude,
what's going on in here man?
Because he's,
he keeps talking shit.
We a beautiful,
like he's totally out of position.
Dustin [inaudible] feet were totally
out of position and Johnson landed a
perfect shot.
Look at the referee,
lost his shoe first ever.
First time ever.
That's what you get.
Skechers Bam.
It's interesting from the other angle
because his feet were completely out of
position and then he cracked him again.
Damn.
What could this look at?
Where it portrays feed are?
Look at where Atlanta.
Great defense by John's.
Yeah.
Boom.
Beautiful.
Bam,
Bam.
How cool would it be if he had
a line to the truck from here?
Like you could talk,
you know,
you know when you're working with a show,
look at that.
Look at that fucking walk,
Dude.
It took security and even Dan,
Margaret Yankton down the cage was like,
Dude,
calm down.
Even the cut man was like,
dude,
chill.
He's still doing shit.
He's still doing that.
Giving my money thing.
Give me my paper.
Wow.
See,
see,
this is where I was like,
why are you cutting away
from the controversy?
Put It on,
let's hear what these guys
are saying to each other.
Yeah.
I could see what Johnson was saying too.
I'd much rather meet them up in this.
Yeah,
Mike,
him up.
I love me some Dan Hardee,
but I'd much rather see
those two jaw and at it.
Well,
you know there's time for that and then
this time for this after that's done.
It's true.
It's also time for fucking Burger.
Can let them jot each other.
Come on folks.
Let's see what they said.
I mean,
they must have said some awful shit to
each other for Johnson and knock them out
and still be mad.
He must've been saying some more awful
shit for security and the cut man be
like,
hey,
let's let's relax a little you one.
My man pretty amped up.
It's always weird to me when guys
are mad after the fight you one man,
you physically beat me up.
Let's relax.
Yeah,
it's always weird to me.
Wow.
So that's a setback and a
half or pour your that high.
You get that high?
Like I just,
I'm a fucking conquer now.
I don't want to take any shit now.
You just want to fuck more people up.
Right.
I could only imagine because I've
never ever fucked anybody up.
I could never imagine.
All I do is as a,
have you had an animosity Joe Schilling?
You have,
you,
you beat a guy.
Let's say there's bad blood
before you guys fight.
Do you carry on,
do you hold that bad blood in the
locker room kind of get it out?
I think so,
yeah.
Usually.
Have you ever fought a guy where it's
just bad mad shit talking like it was like
out of control
on Twitter and shit?
Uh,
yeah.
I've had like a couple like beef,
so like that where we
had like multiple fights.
Me and Levin had three fights.
Me and uh,
I followed Simon Martin.
Twitter's telling each
other to fuck off and chat.
Uh,
not really.
I don't think Twitter was one of the
interviews and went back and forth space.
The lemon one was weird because Levin
pulled out of your fight and then he
fought Simon.
Mark is after that and,
and just stop fighting
at one point in time.
Right?
Like what,
what happened in that fight with
the assignment and 11,
I was there and I still
don't know what happened.
Uh,
I think uh,
can you got a,
a,
a warning or something for
hold for holding are I think,
uh,
he got an eight count.
I think they fell between the ropes
and the and 11 and get back in the room
during fast enough.
So they give him a standing
eight count and he got pissed.
Yeah.
He just quit like halfway
through the fight.
Just got up,
walked out of the ring,
quit.
And he hasn't really fought since.
How's he?
No,
I don't think so.
You were saying that you didn't
think that he wanted to find anymore?
It was like one of those
things like the reason why,
yeah.
I can't imagine anybody like I lost,
like I had respect for him
even though we had like,
he was like,
we're rivalry,
but,
and then when he did that,
I just,
you're like the champion and you're
representing kickboxing and representing
your country and representing
all of this like shit.
And you quit because the,
you know,
you took
ball home and the,
and then gave up your world title.
It was ridiculous.
You know what I mean?
He got out of the ring
defending his title and quit.
That was just weird.
He never,
you don't see that,
you know,
be a shouldn't if Johnson talk shit here,
I think he's calmed down because
they just hugged each other.
You know?
Let's hear what he's saying.
Pay me Baby.
What's up?
Wow.
See everybody's going WWE.
Well,
but pay me what's up.
Maybe if it's a contract
crank repass changing,
dude,
this is a beautiful combination.
Look at this crank bang.
Hmm.
Don't,
don't make Nate,
Nate Diaz get in shape now.
I just a division one wrestler as well.
Yeah,
very good wrestler.
It's just weird how the
referee lost his shoe.
Do you tie your shoes?
What's going on buddy?
They're sketchers.
Have you ever lost your
shoe in a scramble?
There's cancers.
Maybe they should be wearing wrestling to
the Chandler.
Gave him a flat tire.
If you watch that back,
no one should be sketchers
in a street fight.
You mean pour Yay or Johnson.
I'm just kidding.
Oh,
look at this.
Boom.
How did he lose the shoe?
Look,
he'd already laid out right there.
That's a bad angle.
I think.
Damn a flat.
A flat tire.
That's Dan.
You know what it was?
She was probably too small because
dance feeder so fucking big.
You probably didn't have any shoes that
fit him because Dan Merkel Jada's a
giant,
giant man.
18 shoe couldn't find whether
the mall and he's a fuck boy.
Give me the 16 he looks like he should
be wearing those new balance cause
they're extra white foot.
You know what I'm saying?
Like people white feet
have those new balances,
those weird old new balances.
Maybe put the 16 on,
but he said,
I just won't tie him.
It's not going to go away.
And you know that that's
the worst that could happen.
Function for the Ufcu that SAP Spanish,
you can hear the Spanish commentary.
What if the UFC came to you and said,
we want to add an option to listen to
the bike can penguin and they see the
problem with that is then we would
have to guarantee we're going to do it.
We don't always want to do it.
Yeah.
You know like sometimes where I would
tell like the beautiful thing about the
fight and pain is where we're independent.
You know,
we get together and we really
wouldn't be doing this anyway.
We'd be $2 billion.
Okay,
get what I gotta do.
But you'd also have to want to
hang out with Lorenzo and Italy.
I want to get a yacht.
It'd be like what's hot is that?
Is that the end?
Is the yacht,
is that still the yard in the
helicopter and the private jet?
That's the last shit
island is
the last islands where you land
your yacht or your helicopter.
But by the time,
by the time you have an island,
you already have a yacht in
a helicopter ride in a jet.
It's like you're a white
belt at being a billionaire,
right?
Yeah.
It's like,
okay,
you got to yet.
That's cute.
Standard Uber Boat.
Oh Dude.
He got lit up.
God Damn,
it was delicious stoppage.
That was ferocious.
What's the latest on jet packs?
I mean joke in 2000 about how,
why the fuck?
Cause they had jet packs in the 70s
that was in 2016 they had jet packs on
chips.
I don't know if you're over 40 you
might remember chips with Erik Estrada.
I love chips.
They're fucking a jet packs back then.
You telling me that was real.
She should be mastered.
Yes.
They've had jet packs.
You could,
you could.
Hey,
if they weren't real.
I believe it.
I believe I was in Denver with my,
my boy Willie from KBP AI low six,
seven and willy took me
into the parking lot.
They had a,
a,
a show that they did live from the
parking lot where a dude fluid jetpack.
So jetpacks do exist.
But the dude who fluid
had two ACL braces on.
I said,
what?
I go,
what's up with the ACL brace?
Does he like,
dude,
I fucking crashed the thing so
many times for my legs apart.
He goes,
at this point,
I'm not even going to
bother getting it fixed.
Yeah,
they have them,
but that this guy had this guy,
this is a,
this is a much newer
prototype with Willie.
Um,
and the gentleman who we saw
this was like 2000 so good looks.
So back then they could only do it.
He said they could only
fly for 30 seconds.
So what would happen is he would go 15
seconds up and then it would take about,
he really wanted to go down.
He said,
I'd like to land in about five seconds.
He's like,
because I don't,
I've needed a buffer at like 30 seconds.
You're basically out of juice.
That's awesome.
Pleat wastes of time.
Hey,
but for now,
see the thing is virtual
reality that for 50 years,
the thing is virtual reality
used to be a waste of time too,
until the computers and
the technology caught up.
Now they have virtual reality
that will freak you the fuck out,
man.
There's a crazy virtual
reality you showed me.
No,
no,
you never did it.
He never did it.
I didn't show you anything.
No,
I didn't.
I didn't show you never put a goggle on.
You never went and saw the graph and no,
no,
no.
You,
you're seeing it in two dimensions.
It doesn't mean anything.
When you put that goggles on and
you're looking around in this world,
even if the graphics
aren't perfect day freak,
you the fuck out.
They get weird.
You're walking a wire in a canyon.
It's and you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm scared of heights.
Even in this fucking,
I was in some hallway
where there's a boxing.
What kind of Shit?
Here's a boxing one.
Yeah,
we,
you boxes guy.
It's weird because you hold these handles.
You got to hold them like this for your
fist to look like this and the game.
It's very strange.
So like you looks like you're hitting
the guy like this with your hands,
but you're really doing this in the air.
It's so it's not 100% like
boxing technique but you
could change that mean you
could definitely change it
to you're putting something
in your hand and wherever
position your hand is in,
that's the position the gloves would
be in and then it would feel a lot more
natural.
But it's very,
this is what it looks like.
It's very rudimentary right now.
But for as far as like movement and as
far as like teaching someone how to avoid
punches and counter,
you don't feel anything
when you hit him but you,
you do have to move
correctly in order to hit it.
What happens if you throw
the right technique,
the punches just,
it doesn't snap with it.
You should have happens if you do throw,
it doesn't matter because it's not
based on how the punch actually what,
what position that glove is when it lands.
It's based on whether
the glove lands to do it.
Like with like some kind of helmet that
electroids connect to your brain where
you could kind of feel when you yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
And get zapped a little zap.
But then that
that gives you a Parkinson's
quicker than actual trauma.
Well,
here's what happened.
The dude in the video game caught me
with a punch and that when they catch it,
you see a flash that's kind of,
and it gives you the same feeling
that happens when you get,
you're like,
oh shit,
I better,
I better wait flash.
Yeah.
But it gives you that,
oh shit,
we're in trouble.
It gives you like that same little
weird endorphin rush if you get actually
punched in the face.
It's very interesting.
Very interesting.
So what I'm thinking is if
someone develops a program
where they take a guy like
you and Joe Schilling does his
kickboxing techniques and you literally,
I mean it's going to have
to be like one or two more,
uh,
like versions of this improvements,
but it's going to get to a point where
it's virtual and to the point where it's
super high resolution.
So they could hire a guy like you
to throw kicks and punches and in a,
in a computer simulation where all of
your different kicks and punches are all
programmed in there along
with like patterns that you
might use and someone can
actually practice fighting you without
fighting you like your opponent.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
Kind.
Kinda like you would,
you would get used to
seeing you across the cage.
That'd be illegal to steal
someone's fucking moves.
Imagine you sold your
fucking program to the enemy.
Like imagine your elder or training where
you need a partner that you're doing
that.
It's like,
yeah,
I,
you're basically doing I
training at that point of some,
a drill where you're doing actual real
time had moment where that shit you could
do it.
I'm telling you the couch
laying in bed right now.
It's attached to a cord.
So it would be weird for
like spinning things.
It'd be weird if you're trying to throw
spinning elbows or spinning kicks or
move too much.
You know,
if you had too much footwork,
you might get tangled up in this.
But how long for this
motherfucker's wireless.
And once that thing's wireless,
then you just wear a helmet and you're
basically in some enter the dragon room
because you set these things
up and we're Dunkin had it,
he had it in his office,
which is essentially like
the same size of this room.
You've got a camera up there and a camera
up there and it makes a grid on the
ground.
And that grid on the ground is the,
the battlefield.
A grid is where you do cut out.
Like there's an archery game and that
grid represents a tech castle and these
invading armies are coming and you're
shooting at them with bows and arrows?
Dude,
it's already in his backpack.
So it's off of uh,
like big wires.
It's not fully wireless Xbox on
it that looks wireless to me.
Is that a,
what is a,
which version is this James
is to say it's the vibe.
It's the same thing you used
the whole computer is in her,
on her back.
Is that an try them?
It's a company like Msi I believe,
which is a for sale Joe or
Dunkin's maybe Dunkin
got like a prototype.
No,
I mean for him to try it out.
Yeah.
Eddie,
you could try it out at Dunkin's
house now you can buy them.
Yeah.
You don't need that.
There's not a place like
where you can go like a,
like an Internet cafe where
that a bunch of different,
now they put you in a room,
eight bucks an hour.
It's going to knock yourself out.
It's going to happen.
I'm telling you this technology is
going to change the fucking world.
There's no arcades anymore.
Right?
Like they didn't get,
let's try going to castle park.
I take my son there like
every once or twice a week.
Castle Park,
we were there today.
I shit the pat take care still.
As long as there's kids,
there's going to be video games in
arcades cause that on the weekends,
Catlin and miniature golf,
they don't even have to
take care of the fuck.
I'm going to miniature golf.
Make sense?
It's packed on the weekends,
man.
Holy.
And during the summer you got kids.
You want to take them to fun places
and arcades are killing it though.
There's arcades,
arcades and do it right like those
Dave and busters are everywhere.
They're all across the country.
They have all kinds of kids.
Didn't busters counseling,
all kinds of crazy games.
Anything for kids.
I get the big blockbuster movies
for kids all the Goddamn time.
Everything's for kids and music for kids
and fucking Brittany Spears and Justin
Bieber.
I get it.
Do you want to,
you wanna make your kids
happy and all that boasts.
They liked that Bolus ride.
He Spanish 10 note glove toys r us.
Brittany Spears is not for little kids.
These are speakers that neither.
It's like a horny secretaries.
Britney spears girls was
just sitting there typing,
thinking about Dick,
you're going to be taking your kid to
toys r us eventually just took to get on
the bikes and then he's just going to
be riding his bike like the shining and
shit and he was falling.
He though you'd take him there
to ride the bikes and then,
and then eventually one of the,
the,
the cashiers there one out
of three times we'll say,
you can't just be riding
these bikes like the shining,
like all through the,
through the every aisle around the
whole giant toys r us in Burbank.
Well,
I like seeing what,
I was just there with my son the
other day at babies r us toys or us.
This one now it's like one big ass place.
The toys are very similar.
When I was there.
It's still a teenager,
Ninja Turtles,
GI Joes,
action figures,
micro machines,
but they're really not
micro this regular now,
but same shit really gets
going to be on your phone.
Gone through your pictures and shit.
No,
no,
that's fine.
No,
that's going to happen for sure.
It's going to happen.
Going to be said when
your kid and he's like,
can I see a video?
Can I see the video?
You're going to be watching a video.
He's going to want to see it too.
What are you going to say?
No,
you're going to be sitting there.
You guys going to be
looking at videos together,
music videos and shed on your phone
while it's going to have a Pokemon go
account on your phone.
It's going to have
so he,
it's not,
nothing's easy,
but having a business where
kids come for entertainment,
man,
that's like,
once you figured that out,
that's forever.
Like there's a place called uh,
uh,
Biz,
a dizzy bees and a Valencia.
It's a giant place with these tubes
and slides and the kids go nuts there.
Billy B's,
if you've heard of Billy B's in Valencia,
gigantic to place to park.
Where all these crazy,
it's fun for adults.
I know when they,
when my kid was sliding down,
it's,
it's awesome.
What are you showing us up?
Virtual reality check man.
Dubai.
These guys are flying
on these self propelled.
I think they have to live from a plane.
Whoa.
That shit.
It's like a how long
they go for holy Shit.
That's amazing.
They said,
fuck your 30 seconds.
I wonder how long that the tank last.
Holy Shit.
These guys are human planes.
Birds.
Oh my God.
That's it.
That's
like in the future.
This is what it's gonna
look like and working on it.
We need that investment.
They're trying to invest in.
They show them right when all the sky,
no,
Eddie,
it's real.
This is 100% real.
I've already seen this.
Oh,
you've seen it.
This is real.
Look how close they are to the Gen Ed.
So bad.
So dangerous.
What if it catches fire?
Like a Samsung phone just burns your dick
30 only catches your deck on fire and
then it goes out your ditch.
That takes suicide
bombing the whole fucking
undo those straps.
And I'd be like,
we're done here.
We're just going to go
30,000 feet and out.
Fuck,
you're flying squirrel suit.
It's just not my way.
Didn't red bull have one?
What they the first to do it,
but it wasn't a jet propelled.
It was like a suit.
That's still Paris show.
That's so crazy.
One false move.
And they're dead as fuck
for shut up chem trails.
Yeah.
There Kim Cherry on the fuck out of Dubai.
My friend Andy,
he does.
Uh,
he does those wingsuits see that's in,
which is even crazier because he
doesn't even have an engine behind it.
And they're like right there.
Like right.
Have you ever seen him crashed?
One of those things.
I saw the video of one guy from a Gopro,
like from his point of view
where he hits the ground,
he just timed it shitty
in a fuck your night up.
And I'm always going a hundred something
miles an hour to I hit the person.
You can't,
sorry.
You can't see the aftermath of it.
You can just see him hit.
But people
watching it.
Yeah,
pull it up.
Yeah.
I'd love to see a Jamie.
Let's send this fucker with that.
I knew the brand side.
What is it?
It's people love fucking thrills,
man.
I mean,
why do we like this uh,
Johnson [inaudible]
because we love thrills,
right?
We'll have craziness.
How Jesus and people love watching things
and they love doing thrilling things
and some people just have to,
they just have to go so far to get there.
Dick car coming and he's coming in at
gorgeous a bunch of people on a bridge and
he was trying to be a
little bit of a hot dog,
they said and trying to go really
closer than he was supposed to come.
God Dog.
Like one guy went under the bridge and
one guy went over and he's the guy that
was going over.
I had a friend who was into this,
hold on a second.
Hold on.
Hello.
Oh my God.
He just hit the bridge.
That sound is him hitting
the bridge called,
I'll play that back.
And they see that other guy,
there's another guy that was behind him.
Yeah.
He wouldn't play that sound again.
Hold on a second.
That's came
son.
Whoa.
But then one more time.
What's that sound?
Listen to the sound.
Oh,
they knew the guy saying,
oh shit.
Before I knew it was blacks.
It was training for this.
You gotta do so many
skydiving jumps to do this.
And by the time he was,
uh,
like a qualified to do it,
like a base jump show,
many of his group have died
that he decided to back out.
It's like,
too many people are dying.
These guys die all the Goddamn time.
These guys,
one wrong move and you're dead.
It's over.
Oh Shit.
Fuck man.
Holy Shit.
God.
Where's?
He just can't have any for steaks.
Oh look what it did to the bar.
That's a,
that's a fish.
I don't know
who's that.
That's something else.
Go down a wound rabbit hole on youtube.
Like,
you know when I was a kid,
you had to work to get a
copy of faces of death.
You had to actually go out.
You got to seek it.
You got to go to that weird
area of the video store.
You had a rented,
you gotta hope somebody else
hadn't rented it before.
You any little fucking kid whose parents
aren't paying attention can go on
youtube now and watch dudes bounce off
of cliffs and buildings get run over by
trucks.
Isis car headwinds.
If you too doesn't catch it.
Those things,
they stay on for a while and keep
fucking high school kids are probably the
first to find those things.
You got a smart little fucker.
He's on that under web
looking at all sorts of shit.
God,
man.
What the input inputs that someone's
mind under and the dark web.
That seems like such a trap.
Like,
yeah,
it's an under web.
You could do all the
black lips are really sad.
Yeah,
but it just seems like it's a trap.
The trap.
Well then you can't do
all sorts of crazy shit.
They've arrested people.
The guy who created a that a website.
What was the website?
Silkroad yeah,
he uh,
he's actually in jail for life.
For facilities out.
Not as I say,
it's not out there.
It's pretty interesting doc.
I don't know if it's a documentary
is the way you want to word it,
but on Viceland show,
I think it's a,
I can't remember the name of it,
but they take a guy onto the dark web.
They,
they show you like,
this is going on a website,
here's the Ebay,
here's how you can buy stuff with bitcoin.
Oh look,
there's heroin.
Where do you get,
like how do you trade my,
I wonder if that's not been
tightened up because of the trial.
The trial was really crazy because
it turns out that the DEA agents,
the people who are investigating them,
wind up stealing the bitcoin money.
So the investigating guys wound up
stealing hundreds of thousands of dollars.
And then the guy who created the whole
thing still wound up going to jail.
So there was obviously some fuckery and
shenanigans and real corruption going
on.
And uh,
this dude's in jail for life.
He's in jail for life and they,
but they said that,
see,
I don't really know what he did,
but I think they said
that he was trying to,
uh,
get someone murdered or that was
like one of the possibilities,
right?
That someone had a,
suggested they murder somebody and
he was trying to set something up.
Well that makes sense.
Can Be ordered.
Killings of people were
watching that movie that,
uh,
Alex wintered made that he was in bed.
You can learn a lot about it.
Yeah,
he didn't believe it.
Alex didn't believe it.
There's an interesting documentary.
I've watched the documentary
before Alex came in.
He didn't believe it.
But the reality is he doesn't know.
You know,
you don't,
you don't really know what a guy did
or didn't do unless you were there.
It's just,
I don't,
I mean,
we know the cops were liars though.
They were stealing money.
Like they're very cops that were in charge
of the case were stealing money from
the soup.
He counts.
So the whole thing is so crazy.
Jamie is anonymous.
Like how do they still work?
How does that work?
What does do you know
is anybody can be in,
you don't,
you know,
there's no like fucking meetings.
It's just a bunch of people online.
They're tired of bullshit.
Smart paper.
That really smart people.
Yeah.
How do you know it's not fake?
Like how come?
Cause they're all wearing math.
How do you know people
aren't putting fake?
How do you know the fake?
Well,
here's the thing.
Can Be,
anybody can be there.
I mean,
I don't know.
how would you,
I would have to talk to someone who's
legitimately in anonymous to get the full
details.
Still going strong.
And they're still fighting crime,
right?
They definitely do.
They definitely catch people
that have done fucked up shit.
Oh yeah,
there was a girl,
well,
I remember one story about a girl
who was throwing puppies in a,
in a river.
I remember that Shit.
And they found her and they,
they'd doxed her information and then,
you know,
they've,
they've done some things,
you know,
they've closed down and hacked into
databases and companies are doing shady
shit.
What's going on in here?
New.
But a Ra did a podcast with a couple
of guys down where in anonymous or they
claim to be an anonymous.
So if you want to find that out,
you can check out skeptic tank 79 and
[inaudible] talked with a couple of guys.
I'm just confused as how,
how it's organized and excellent.
Is there,
is there an anonymous,
uh,
like an official,
there's an sure.
Twitter like nick who runs down enough
the cabbie because then like people
wouldn't know who they are.
I got to say before I forget,
uh,
Ari Shaffir,
his latest podcast is with Henry Rollins.
Those who wander are not on,
not all those who wander are lost.
It's fucking amazing that
Henry Rollins guy's crazy.
He's crazy.
It goes all over the world.
No,
he's amazing.
Amazing.
I,
I'm buying for a total new
found appreciation for him
after listening to him on
that podcast.
He told me his work ethic,
we work with the same guys for our live
shows and they were telling us about
Henry Rollins and his work
ethic on the live shows.
It's insane,
man.
I can only imagine.
He goes to these weird places,
he picks a spot in the world,
travels there and spends like a month
there and just brings a typewriter or or
rather a a a camera and maybe a laptop
and do you know his clothes and shit and
just lives with these people and
just just goes to like Kuala Lampur.
Okay,
let's try that place.
Don't it goes by himself,
goes and hangs out,
takes a photos during the day and
at nighttime write stories about it.
You know when he writes stories for
a bunch of different publications,
I don't want to give away any more of it
because it's just awesome podcasts and
string dude.
Yeah.
Are ran into him.
I think Ra was in Stockholm and he was
doing standup and Henry Rollins was,
they were doing something
else and they met up.
So interesting guy.
Yeah.
Well even,
I mean I,
I always thought he was very smart and
interesting and very passionate about a
lot of things,
but hearing them on Ari's podcast gave
me a whole different appreciation for
them.
I feel like you guys would connect.
Maybe it's certain things.
I think it'd be fun.
Maybe it hate me or maybe you hate him.
I don't think so.
Now you guys be friends.
Yeah.
I think listening to him
on the [inaudible] podcast,
I would find him completely fascinating.
I just really respect that.
Completely off the beaten path choice
of just decided he goes to these places
and they'll just go and,
you know,
hang out in Afghanistan or go,
it's kind of always been a guy.
He's done it his way,
which you can appreciate it.
Yeah.
I mean we started off as a musician
and then now what he does is he writes,
and he does like the spoken word things
apparently is doing a run at Largo in
December.
So I might go down there and check that
live shows bad ass and it sells out like
a motherfucker.
Well,
I mean it's uh,
it's interesting,
he's kind of like kind
of doing standup but not,
you know,
he's really just telling stories
about things so he's not confined,
which is um,
you know,
a lot of,
a lot of people find like a podcast
very freeing because it's one of the few
times that comics are,
aren't confined to this constant
need to be funny like all the time,
like over and over and over again.
Like sometimes it shows they're
just funny back and forth,
funny back and forth.
But some you don't have to like sometimes
there's a moment in a podcast where
you just have to,
you want to kind of explore something.
You can't really do that on stage though.
You know,
like a comic can't really do that on
stage unless they do some sort of a weird
artsy one person show,
you know.
But a guy like Rawlins,
he doesn't have like any defined
pattern that has shows have to follow.
Yeah.
He's not in a box.
He's not a comedian like he
can get up there and do you,
I know he has his guitar.
He tells these epic stories from his life.
Yeah,
you're right.
I'll do whatever you want.
You're not going to that
show gone make me laugh.
Clown.
He did laugh in the
first 10 or 15 minutes.
Go,
go.
It's kind of interesting what you
guys do with fighter in the kid too.
It's cause like you're doing a podcast,
but you do a podcast live and you're
doing this podcast live and it's kind of a
comedy show,
but it's kind of whatever the
fuck you want it to be show,
you know,
you can kind of make your own
sort of format of entertainment.
Like the,
the live podcast format is a new
form of entertainment in a way.
And I've only done a couple of them.
I did one of my own and
bunch of other people's ones.
And the thing,
the interesting thing about
it is it's not the same thing.
When an audience is there,
when you're doing it live,
it becomes way more of like they,
they're attention span is taken
into consideration much more.
Yeah,
and I,
Brian had the great idea because to
to perform like it's a performance,
you know they're scripted parts.
It's broken up the segments
because when he decided to do it,
I did my research and I went
to some of the life podcast.
I'm like,
dude,
these people are loyal fans devoted,
but this is boring man.
It's just two guys on a mic talking.
There's not much to see and especially
if you're in a comedy plays like if
you're doing the store or hit the Bray
Improv with are used to seeing big acts
and people who entertain.
You got to kind of do your thing,
man.
You're not going to,
he'll just talk like buddies.
You got to have a plan.
Yeah.
If you're doing a big venue for sure.
If you do it like Kevin Smith used to
have this little theater in Hollywood and
I did a podcast there with him.
I did one with Norton there.
I did my podcast there with
Norton a long time ago.
And uh,
his theater only seats,
like,
I don't think he has it anymore,
but it only seats like 40 people.
It's like this tiny little place.
It's like essentially like a,
an acting studio where people
would take acting classes and then,
you know,
they'd come down to the stage
and perform and like it's,
it's,
it was so intimate.
It was bizarre.
Was this format,
was it like a podcast?
Cause then I don't think you
have to put on a show as much.
Exactly.
Podcast.
Yeah,
but it's a podcast in
front of a really small,
super,
super intimate crowd.
Like almost too intimate.
Like Wally George,
remember that?
Wally George,
I remember Wally.
George.
I do,
but I don't,
the 80s he does.
He,
the guy with the weird
hair and he was on pike.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh that's right.
He's like cable TV guy was in the audience
of one of these shows because they
would cut to the audience he was in.
He filmed in Hana hot areas.
I gotta I gotta Piss.
Oh,
keep this going with that.
You don't remember.
Wally.
George are too young for that,
right?
I don't,
while he's insane.
What's he from?
He had this,
uh,
I guess it was like,
you know that,
um,
uh,
what uh,
what's it called?
Free Access TV
show.
There's channel a six in Denver,
Colorado and he,
he filmed an Anaheim
and he was super like,
just like his character was a total d bag,
but Super Republican d
bag and yelled at people.
He was just over the God
damn doing it for ratings.
A hot seat.
That's,
that's the name of it.
It was.
Do you still do your podcast,
Eddie?
No,
man.
You should stop doing it.
Yeah,
I just,
it's just,
uh,
maybe I'll come back and do it.
Maybe I will,
but I guess we did like 60 or 70 episodes.
I'm like that.
I don't even remember.
I never go back and listen to
him and I sat in enough shit.
I'm like,
do I want to be a fucking host?
I don't want to be a host to shit.
You know,
maybe I'll change it.
Maybe I will,
but I don't want to be that guy who
says same shit over and over again.
Because when you're,
when you're running a show,
it's you do,
you have to,
you have to repeat that story because
some people haven't heard it and then the
people who have heard at your
hardcore fans will just stare.
It goes with that fucking show.
That's on your story too.
Cause did you have a partner
or was it just you ride?
Man,
I'd have a roomful of people.
I just invited five people at a time
just to have just conversation just like
this.
I wanted it four or five people to talk,
but after awhile I do,
I get sick of hearing myself
tell the same goddamn story.
I think I've said enough.
I think I said enough.
I mean I do.
I want to be a host of some shit.
Well listen,
when you really don't feel
like I want to be a host,
they manage to do a podcast.
Guys,
you know,
you could always do this one.
You know,
you always,
you can always come on and do my podcast.
I'm not talking about being like being,
uh,
I'm saying that's what I'm saying.
Like if you just want to do it
occasionally and just get the itch out,
you know,
you've got an open invitation.
I,
uh,
you know the,
have you heard of that show rock line?
It's been on for 30 years.
Bob Coburn Kalo as big shirts like that,
guns and roses kiss,
like all the big biggest Rick rock legends
we'd get on Keller West once a week.
It's called rock line.
It's huge in La.
The,
um,
well Bob Coburn came down with,
uh,
some kind of cancer,
whatever,
and the show is on hiatus
and the producer of the show,
he wants me to bring my podcast back.
And,
uh,
he said,
dude,
let me put together something for you.
And,
and I'm on the fence about it.
I'm on,
if,
you know,
if we do this,
how,
you know,
who knows?
Who knows who?
I Dunno.
Listen to your fun guy to man.
Just do it.
It's not like you don't
sign a contract or anything,
just do it.
I didn't have to be just like you said,
they'd have to be in a way where I,
if I want to just to,
uh,
just do it on my pace.
I don't want people like,
Oh,
you got to do with you and show studio.
You have a studio.
My Studio,
my studio actually sucks because it's
a rehearsal studio and sometimes we'll
have guests and there's
a drummer that practices,
I've done cow with the drummer
just shredding for two hours.
I've done that.
If it becomes a problem,
well,
you don't want it Joe's,
right?
Like you don't want like
same with the companions.
Like let's say someone's like,
Yo,
we want to take this on,
pay you guys a jillion dollars.
It,
it takes the fun out of it.
If it's work,
if we have to see each other once a week,
bitch listen to me.
Well,
if a billions different,
if I decided to try to do like,
just to test it out,
um,
maybe I'd take you up on your offer and,
and uh,
maybe,
uh,
you know,
who knows?
Maybe,
um,
you know,
it sounds like you don't know.
I don't know.
I'm on the fucking fan side
thing.
Listen,
if you ever want to do it from here,
like one day just for a goof,
just bring it back one day for a goof.
You know,
we could do it together.
I might do that.
You should do whatever the fuck you want
to do and you stopped doing it for a
reason.
You stopped doing it because you're so
overwhelmed with responsibilities with
family,
which of Jitsu teaching has run an Ebi
tie or it is a lot going on with that.
It's like fuck I am I going
to have a podcast run EBI,
run 10th planet and
make music and my fuck.
When's a lot going on too much.
It's still a lot going on there.
I got my son there and these are the
most important years of his life and you
know,
I'm hanging out with him and
I'm trying to shut things off.
Um,
I'm really focusing on trying
to just shut the world off.
Was Your podcast making money?
Well,
no.
No.
I never tried to even
look for fucking sponsors,
man.
I just,
I was just doing it on my,
uh,
my own free time and
just for the fun of it.
And I think I've said enough man,
they're the,
all the episodes are still up on youtube.
I don't want to fuck,
let me tell you something man.
Even having sponsors,
even having sponsors is a fucking,
is a responsibility you have to consider
is what have you ever sponsored that's
not good.
And I go to a response or that rips
people off or something that where it goes
wrong.
Like there was a sponsor that came to me,
which is like an Uber for Nannies for
like people taking care of your kids.
It's like you can call us a right idea.
It's a terrible idea.
You don't even know this part.
What did they behave like?
Uber drivers.
You don't even know
how I heard it for a second.
I go no fucking way.
I was like no blocking guaranteed
that run through like a rigger on,
on chat.
You've got gotta be careful that stuff.
And I've had this conversation with
Joe before to certain sponsors.
We've,
we've,
we've turned down,
I won't say the name of the company to
Mag a sponsor because cal and I a don't
believe in the product.
B are our audience.
Be like,
get the fuck Outta here.
This isn't really,
it was just doing it for a paycheck.
So we turned them down.
We had one that was a soup company and
super suit suit and you'd have to go get
tailored and they send the suit in
the mail like these worldclass suits.
What's wrong with that?
Well,
what's wrong with that is both are mine
and counts came in the mail and they
were just so shitty.
Can't do this because dude's going to
order suits and then they come all shitty.
And then I'm like,
dude,
this is,
you know,
can't have it.
You know how it goes.
Well that's smart that you guys did that.
That's smart because the last thing you
want to do is disappoint your fans in a
way like that where you can avoid it.
You know,
it's one thing if you get tricked,
but if you,
uh,
if you could avoid it,
it's his hard because right now there
it's really opening up the market as far
as,
um,
people that are advertising on podcasts,
but they're still,
they're not like mainstream names.
You don't hear like Chevrolet
advertising on podcasts or you know,
Samsung,
I had your Samsung did.
Well,
they should if to Latin mass,
not shit on him.
Well,
if they're smart,
they,
because there's no better
platform for loyal listeners.
Then a fucking podcast who's going
to listen to and talk for whatever,
six hours a week,
nine hours a week.
They're dedicated and until
there's nothing like it,
TV ain't shit.
Oh,
32nd commercial ain't shit.
If people want to fast forward,
no one's watching.
T I have 500 fucking channels.
I Never Watch TV.
I watch TV,
sports,
I watch now.
I watch Netflix.
I generally don't,
I'm always on my apple TV.
I'm always on Netflix,
always on the apple,
always on that flicks.
The only time I watch regular TV is when
the ultimate fighter comes on or so I'm
just saying the advertisement
as far as podcasts,
if they were smart man with uh,
with your audience or someone
like Dan Carlin or NPR,
like dots where it's at these days,
more and more they will
more and more they grow.
Dan Carlin told Tommy's in a weird
position because he gets a fuck load of
downloads,
but he does his podcast so infrequently
that the best model for him as far as
cash is actually to do
it through subscriptions.
So when you order it from iTunes,
like especially the older episodes,
it costs a dollar 99
that makes sense for him.
But let me tell you something,
it is worth so much more than that.
Like his fucking podcast or
they're like a work of art.
Correct.
Cool.
Dan Carlin,
he's got,
I'll,
I'll send you a link
to a hardcore history,
wrath,
wrath of the cons all about
Gingiss Khan and the Mongol Empire.
If he was our history teacher and we
would all be fucking into history,
love history,
he's such a dynamo.
He was on last week and my podcast,
he's such a dynamic guy and we were just
talking about seeing above cars son.
I love that dude.
He's so awesome.
You guys,
are you guys open the show
with flat earth stuff?
No,
no,
no.
Not Two sweater.
Felicia.
What's that?
Michael Shermer.
Yeah,
Dan Carlin to slap somebody.
If you brought that up though.
Yeah,
he's not really into flat earth,
but it's,
he's,
he's got such a deep knowledge of so
much fucking history and he prepares for
months to get these things ready.
That's how it's different,
right?
Like a lot of podcasts,
like you know,
like you,
like you said on the show,
you just turn on you having a
conversation with your buddies.
Carlin has to fucking go balls deep
into how he's going to articulate it,
the plan and there's,
you know,
the start and finish in its history.
So it's not an opinion.
Well we were talking
about it and I was like,
you know what we're doing as a podcast
where you're doing is like an audio art
piece.
It's like a work of art.
That's also historically
accurate audio book.
You termed an audio show.
Yeah,
he's white.
Way More of a now I use that.
Where does it get out?
Where did he get his,
uh,
like what is,
he knows obviously he
knows everything on goal.
He can his con where does
it get its information?
He gives you a bunch of
different references that
he uses from various history
books and he also shows the discrepancies
and the opinions how one person
believed it was this but another person.
But so he gives you a
balanced perspective too,
but then relays the undeniable facts.
So he tells you when there's
some vagueness in history,
which I really appreciate too
because he's not dogmatic.
He doesn't have like one idea in his
head of how things absolutely went down.
So,
and he's just so entertaining man.
Cause he has a background in um,
in talk radio.
So he's just so good at being
like a professional broadcaster.
And then the guy's a maniac
when it comes to history.
So he does this.
He did the seat series on World War One.
I have no idea how fucking
crazy world war one was.
No idea on nuts.
That one dude,
you got to live.
They're all good.
He's pretty,
no.
Did you know that Hitler was
actually a soldier in World War One?
Did you talk about that?
And not only with the a soldier,
but he was one of the most,
he got like hardcore purple
heart type shit from Germany.
He did the hardcore shit he wanted.
Is that true?
Go,
hold on.
Hold on real quick.
Dropping knowledge on day.
If I know that you might've read
that from one of those sites.
I mean,
I'd never heard that about,
I heard that he was a hardcore,
he's one serious like awards war time.
He was a war hero.
He got behind them because he was
so hardcore and he's right on this,
I feel like,
is he,
what does he do his,
um,
what does it say here?
Did he was doing it all this stuff.
First job,
the most dangerous job was
sending messages to the
front line from headquarters
at the front line.
That was the worst that
he volunteered for,
that he got hurt.
And could got discharged
and he's all fucked up.
He didn't want to get discharged.
You want it to go back to front,
not graded,
Huh?
Yeah.
He's super crazy.
Super Crazy.
That's interesting.
Take gangster.
I never,
he didn't bring that up
at all but that wasn't,
you know,
obviously if you're going to
do a piece about world war one,
Hitler doesn't play a big part unless
you're going to continue with World War
Two and talk about is serving the
transition I guess if he goes to one.
Yeah,
for sure.
I did not know that.
That's an interesting,
that's an interesting because a
lot of shit about world war two,
that fuck man,
that I didn't know that.
It's fascinating shit.
How we'll work to connects to JFK.
How that all comes together.
Fog.
It's a gnarly shit.
It's way better than fucking uh,
game of Thrones cause it's real cause
it actually really happened to find out.
Exactly because what
you get in high schools,
you get a basic jack and Jill versions
of what the fuck happened because he had
done,
oh,
this guy was shot and then the world went
to war for an Dan whatever and hungry
and there's so much crazy shit involved.
It's really as like a some kind of mini
series like you want to get into World
War II and JFK.
Lot of movies on world war season,
mini series.
It's so complex.
There's so many players.
Jesus go,
if Kalyn was here right now,
he would drop some knowledge on
us about it that he remembers.
Does he remember a lot about World War II,
World War II,
buff?
I don't think so.
He loves history though,
so drop it.
Even if he doesn't know
that's what we do
and I just dropped it.
Thanks.
It's a,
there's
a moment in history where you go back
and look at it and things will never be
the same now Arthur,
right?
No.
Dot.
It's the author.
An idle
time had a Adolf Hitler
is man of the year when
you got the weirdest shit ever.
Yes.
Julian [inaudible].
Man of the year for Time magazine,
man of the year before they turned
before everything went wrong.
But at first ever United States,
Adolf Hitler,
they were into him.
Eddie is dropping some serious words.
Are Real knowledge on
your ass now was Hitler,
was Hitler not a vegetarian?
I Dunno,
I go with,
no,
I think that was,
I think that was a rumor
that Hitler was a vegetarian.
He also did a shitload of judge.
Uh,
I think he was.
He was,
do you know that he was,
you know,
he was an architect and all
the major buildings in all the,
in Germany.
He designed them.
He was into designing
not only the buildings,
but you know those giant Nazi parades
with all the giant crazy shit.
He choreographed and
designed all that shit.
I mean,
what a documentary called
the architect of doom.
It's about Adolf Hitler being,
that's why he started hating the Jews
because he was trying to get into this art
academy that was run by
Jews and they denied him,
Bro.
[inaudible] podcast.
There you go,
dude.
I'm a white petit and world war two.
You guys just haven't even walked into
the gym and that's all it says that prior
to 1937,
he uh,
he ate meat and then after 37 on,
towards the end of his life,
he started becoming vegetarian.
That's why he became crazy.
Apparently had chronic flatulence sort
of thing or as far to not try to smear
him.
Yes.
And he sucked.
Boy's Dick still always
far just like a smear
farting.
How many leaders that far problems?
They probably like 80% of leaders probably
had heart problems or drinking scotch
all fucking night.
Well the um,
the meth thing is crazy because apparently
like a lot of world leaders were on
speed back then.
Like that was a big issue.
Now one of the things about Hillary
Clinton that popped up was that she was on
PR,
I think it was pro vigil or new vigil.
Provigil Provigil is a,
uh,
it's like that,
that stimulant that a fighter
pilots use to stay awake.
Like it keeps you on point.
It's illegal in the Olympics now
because it's some sort of a performance
enhancing.
She's supposed to.
She supposedly on that so,
well,
she's on that.
This is bringing this up is because
this lady was telling me that her,
her friend's husband is on,
he's on Adderall.
She was going off about Adderall.
She's like my friend's
husbands on Adderall.
He takes it every day.
Every day.
Takes Adderall.
Like he says he needs it takes
to keep up the pace of the day.
Like that is math.
Yes.
It's approved.
And then it's like,
it's like the same as math.
It's like you're taking a
controlled dose of meth every day.
How many people are out
there just taking math.
It's a,
you watch breaking bad a lot.
Yeah,
but that's math.
Math,
math,
math.
Jamie pulled up.
How many people are a on Adderall?
Say how many people,
how many prescriptions of Adderall?
What were your fighter pilot drugs called?
What?
Let's just take a guess real quick.
Let's take a guess on Adderall.
Yeah.
How many people on Adderall?
How many prescriptions?
Cause that's all you really know.
You know how many
prescriptions are written?
I don't know what that
means as far as people.
I think 10% what?
How many million?
Give me a million.
How many prescriptions?
300 million.
3 million.
3 million people and now it's seven.
I'm going to go 6 million.
6 million people in that
are almost six months.
More than 6 million.
Well,
let's find out these prescriptions
in 2015 for Adderall did this,
this work.
Think about that.
Like the prescription drugs,
legal.
They are,
how destructive they are,
how dangerous they are,
and they're totally illegal.
And so what happens in Arizona
just sits down and just like,
oh,
everything's fine.
I just believe everything.
They fucking tell me.
Did you see Arizona?
That's the craziest shit ever right there.
Arizona.
They're trying to legalize weed and
the number one funder to go against the
legalization of weed is from the company
that makes that fucking crazy pain drug
that's many times stronger than Oxycontin,
fentanyl or something like that.
This shit that they killed
prince and these these guys,
that's some that joy would say,
this is what it is.
The shit that killed prince,
they'd said it was $500,000
this company donated in Arizona.
Just try to stop this
campaign to legalize.
That should be a fucking felony.
Yeah.
Any kind of,
anything that could can,
can be considered a crime on humanity.
If you can prove that,
that should be a fucking felon.
You can't just do that shit.
That's a crime.
People are people.
People are fucking dying and getting
crazy off these prescription drugs and no
one says shit.
Look at tobacco.
Nobody say shit.
Look at alcohol.
No one says shit.
Then God,
but damn.
And what that,
no shit.
We're going to get out of here.
I got to do a spot at the store,
so I gotta.
I gotta wrap this bitch
up and bring it home,
but I'm fun times.
Boy.
Finally kid live San Jose Thursday
and then Braya and Oxnard in October.
Where's the schedule?
You guys got?
Jack k.com t fat k.com man,
I really think you should
come up with the clothes.
16 Mil site.
I'll be in Decatur,
Alabama.
The Saturday 10th planet,
Decatur,
Alabama.
This Saturday we found a,
Jamie found something.
16 million prescriptions
was in 1999 and 99
that's fine.
3 million.
I had to laugh at that,
but I was,
how many people are using
those 16 million prescriptions?
Like how many prescriptions?
Like how long has the prescription last?
Do you get one every three months?
You know,
what does that mean?
That a person gets four
prescriptions a year,
so you divide that by four went to
eight I think you get fit in days.
It's every 30 days,
right when you need them.
I think if when you get
prescribed hold on son,
just stop the nonsense.
If you're hooked on Adderall,
you're taking that shit every day.
Yeah.
What the doctor's not giving
them to you to use it earlier,
I was on Adderall when
I was in high school.
Yeah.
Now that you get it every day.
I know a guy who has an
Adderall patch hit a pastoral,
all pals or and patch.
It was a riddle and passionate.
They gave him PROZAC.
Pennies on another,
another level.
No,
it was a patch.
It was a patch.
They gave them a patch.
It was some sort of easy
or Prozac or Ritalin,
but he was on Adderall as well.
We tried a bunch of different things,
but he was on Adderall,
z cool.
Every day.
Very cool.
But he was,
he was struggling with fatigue issues.
He's like a not a,
not a vibrant guy taking a
lot of naps during the day.
I don't know.
I don't think he did it.
He's,
he's,
he hustles.
He works,
but I think he was having some problems.
Accessible dude.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Real successful dad
this weekend.
He drives a Prius
Tesla.
Uh,
but he was on it every day.
Jamie.
They do prescribe it for
some people every day.
I didn't,
I wasn't saying that they don't prescribe.
I thought they didn't
prescribe it every day.
I think just a refill.
It'd be 30 I think.
I think there's a lot of
people that take it every day
because they're not going to give
you fucking hundred 20 pills.
No Slang.
I think they do.
And I think if you take one a day,
like that's how they,
I think they can do it.
I don't think it's thought of as being
like the danger that it is fucking idiot
or at least most people like you or I,
they think it's going to help you,
but kids are snorting that
shit and taking classes.
The frills for testing
of people abused it.
I wasn't saying that.
I know.
Have you ever taken it?
I take it.
No,
I'm not getting nothing done.
I will chat.
You're fucking air.
Ah,
nothing done.
Real chatty Kathy on that shit.
I didn't want to it in college.
I mean I got nothing done.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
come on.
Like what are you doing?
Hey,
we're,
we're just fucking going off.
Oh my God.
That idea.
Well that's it.
Um,
Joe Schilling,
one eight seven on Twitter.
Joe Underscores Schilling on Instagram,
correct?
Yes sir.
I'm on the ball.
Boom.
On the bond.
The Brendan Schaub.
Don't call them Brandon.
Brendan,
Brendan.
I'm sorry about that.
I know I fucked up.
Fucked up.
We hope everybody in New York's okay,
Bryan Karens.
Okay.
And appreciate the fuck ID people.
Next one we can do with these.
We'll do it.
I don't know.
Is there an one next week?
Because they're one next week.
When's the Cyborg fight next?
Firing a bitch next week.
Okay.
We gotta do one of the Canelo fight.
Don't we miss the spoiler
alert?
Canelo fight tonight,
okay.
Okay.